and now book TV's monthly in-depth
program with author and journalist Matt
Taibbi mr. Taibbi a contributor at
Rolling Stone magazine is the author of
seven books including the great
derangement grift topia and his most
recent insane clown president dispatches
from the 2016 circus
Matt Taibbi in your most recent book
insane clown president you write about
President Trump quote he's no ordinary
conman he's way above average and the
American political system is his easiest
mark ever yeah well this was that was
early in the campaign I think that was I
think that was in March of 2016 so it
was just around the time when he was
sewing up the Republican nomination and
the purpose of that article is this is
the compilation of articles this book
was sorted to try to explain the Trump
phenomenon to people who were for the
first time having to take it seriously
and having to try to come to grips with
the fact that this was happening and so
you know I took a kind of a different
approach to Trump and tried to really
listen to what his supporters were
saying and try to focus on what he was
doing and you know my take on him is
that he was a brilliant media
manipulator and that he was perfectly
suited to play on all the weaknesses of
the American political media and and
that turned out to be true I wish I had
stuck to my guns in that piece because I
thought that he was going to be
President to her and then and then later
on in the book I you know I didn't
believe that so well the day after the
election you wrote I did not see Donald
Trump coming right everybody wrote that
though didn't I well they did yeah yeah
I mean it's funny I
I did see a long time ago that we were
going to have a problem with this sort
of post factual media atmosphere and
that work for which Trump was perfectly
suited even wrote a book about it a long
time ago called The Grates arrangement
but I never saw Donald Trump
specifically I mean he was a unique
character and I think what was unique
about him was he his insight was that
the American presidential election was
basically just a big reality show but it
was a bad reality show with bad with bad
characters and he made
engrossing impossible to miss reality
show and he was perfectly suited for the
medium well along that line you write
that Donald Trump's innovation was to
recognize what a bad TV show the
campaign was any program that tried to
make stars out of human sedatives like
Scott Walker and Lindsey Graham needed
new producers in a new script exactly
yeah and and we had for a long time in
the media been drifting away from
substantive policy reporting and we had
more and more played up the storytelling
aspect the the production values aspect
of it you know the pageantry the debates
they were they were covered like sports
contests we had pregame shows where
people you know sort of prognosticated
who was going to win you know we had
these amazing graphics with the dial
surveys showing you know how the person
was doing according to what he or she
was saying and Trump he sort of looked
at that format and he said I think
internally he said wouldn't it be
amazing if you put like a professional
reality actor in the middle of this and
took advantage of all this stage craft
and that's what he did I think a lot of
the professional politicians there
they're good enough on camera you know I
think they they're able to deliver a
speech that's been composed by for them
by their other staff but they're not
able to improvise and do what Trump does
and attract attention
the degree that he's able to do well
when you were covering this for Rolling
Stone did you develop a respect for his
campaign style or his ability to not
sure get boats respected is is an odd
word I definitely understood and
appreciated what he was doing I think I
saw early on the Trump was operating on
a different level from the other
candidates I mean there's a scene that I
described in the book where we're at
Plymouth State University in New
Hampshire and you know the press is
always in the middle of the hall right
we're roped off we're behind a rope line
and there's these risers and then the
cameramen are are standing there and
trumpet started to make us part of the
Act
what he would do is he would in the
middle of his speech he would
interrupts himself look at these these
jerks is these vultures you know they
hate me they you know they've never
traveled so far for an event you know
they didn't believe I could do this well
and the crowd would physically turn
toward us and sometimes it would start
to boo and hiss or throw things you know
and it got very menacing and to me this
was it was incredible because Trump was
taking something that was incredibly
boring you know the American political
stump speech which is usually this very
lifeless event with this very scripted
careful kind of delivery and he turned
it into this immediate physical menacing
WWE style performance and it was very
memorable for people you could see that
they left the hall you know sort of
worked up into a lather and I was very
unusual for a political event and it was
hard not to miss how effective that was
going to be you relate the story on
election day that you're standing it
from tower and somebody walked up to you
and asked if you were reporter right
yeah I forget what he said exactly but I
think he swore at me and and when I said
yes I mean I had a lot of experiences
like that and on the trail this year and
this to be fair had been happening for
quite a long time before Trump even came
on the scene reporters had been more and
more unpopular over the years and Trump
he used our unpopularity in a really
interesting way because being a
billionaire from New York he had a huge
accessibility problem with ordinary
people in quote-unquote flyover country
but what he did is he he made a common
enemy out of the media and he presented
us as the elitist you know upper class
enemy and he what he basically said is
we both hate these people and that was
his link to the common man basically and
so that that trick of using us of
bringing us into the speech and making
us characters in the story was
incredibly effective for him it's we
solved his accessibility problem I
thought you called the American
political system an easy mark what do
you mean by that well again the
for example the you-know-what what Trump
did our political system more especially
our system of political media is set up
in a way that's totally irrational and
doesn't doesn't work well for the body
politic we're a commercial system of
media which means that almost all the
people who are covering the presidential
election they need to get ratings and
subscriptions and eyeballs and hits in
order to make money and so anybody who
who does those things who gets ratings
for for the media is going to have a
massive advantage over anybody else
doesn't matter what your policies are if
you're like Donald Trump when you start
making you're making money for the
network's they're going to cover you
more and that was a major major factor
early in the race I think you know there
was a statistic that Trump got twenty
three times the amount of TV coverage
that Bernie Sanders did and that wasn't
for any substantive reason it was
because Trump was making the TV stations
and the newspapers and the magazines
money and the that vulnerability that we
had to somebody who was a good
commercial vehicle made it very easy for
somebody like Trump to come in and just
sort of take over the entire spectacle
what's it like to travel in the
presidential campaign reporting bubble
it's a very difficult and frustrating
assignment the first time I did it for a
long stretch was in 2004 and you're
you're basically stuck in the same
environment with the same people over
and over and over again for days and
days and weeks on end
and especially in the later stages of
the campaign when the Secret Service
gets involved you're literally trapped
in this environment you can't leave the
rope line you have to stay with the same
people and talk to them and you're
you're stuck with the candidate the
candidates aides and other reporters and
they're the only people you're getting
information from and so what happens in
this environment and I think this is a
big factor and what happened with Trump
is that you just don't it you don't
spend a lot of time talking to actual
people and you miss a lot of
important phenomena that are going on
out there and we get our information
from things like polls that tells us
what's going on you know and that's
that's that how we take the temperature
or the people but it's not an accurate
way of kind of discerning what's going
on and that that kind of bubble
it can be very stifling and suffocating
and strange also it's so it's a weird
atmosphere to live in for a long time
now reading your most recent couple of
books tell me if I'm wrong about this
but can you draw a direct line from
howard dean to ron paul to dennis
kucinich to donald trump I think so yeah
I mean they were all they were all
protest candidates right to begin with
if the difference was that in the old
days the press had the power to kind of
take these you know these protest
candidates and kind of marginalize them
right if we if we thought if the sort of
establishment media collectively decided
that a person like Dennis Kucinich was
not a fit for the presidency they would
just describe him as a as not really a
candidate and it would be subtle
sometimes and unsubtle other times and
sometimes it would be the candidate
would be way at the edge in the debate
other times they would describe the
person at the fringe candidate in the
text other times they just simply not
cover the speeches and they would signal
to the audiences who's the real
candidate who isn't the real candidate
right they would so we had the
frontrunners and these are the sort of
curiosities what happened this time
around was that there was so much
animosity towards the system and towards
the establishment media and and toward
this whole kind of Beltway complex
king-making
group that decided who gets to be
president who doesn't get to be
president that they that the voters
poured all their energy into candidates
like Trump and Bernie Sanders who whose
main selling point was I don't belong to
that Club right I mean that that's what
they did they stood up in front of
audience and said look these people over
here
they want to tell you who's going to who
your president is going to be and and
I'm defying that and vote for me and
people flock to those candidacies so in
the old days yeah I mean I watched this
as the press basically tore apart
candidates like Dean and Kucinich and
and also Ron Paul and they tried to do
it to Trump this time except he just he
defied the instinct you know we tried to
get rid of him he just he just wouldn't
have it and he wouldn't exit the stage
do you feel that Rolling Stone and
yourself are part of the mainstream
media uh yeah I mean yes and no we've
we've been around for so long that were
I guess you would call us legacy media
now we're not corporate media I think
that's an important distinction you know
where privately owned and so but you
know our coverage is kind of a tradition
now it's been around for 50 years and
you wouldn't describe us as a you know a
threadbare alternative media publication
anymore I think that would be in an
accurate description so we're somewhere
in between I would say if somebody went
back in red hunter s Thompson from 1972
could they relate to it today absolutely
100 Thompson's books are timeless and
they you know I think of them more as as
being like great works of fiction than I
do you know journalism becomes
irrelevant after in a very short period
of time it's pretty hard to read
you know journalism 50 60 years later
and really really get into it but Hunter
Thompson's books are like great novels
you know I the fear and loathing on the
campaign trail I always think of as I
wrote this once for one of the
introductions to one of those books that
it reminded me of a book like the castle
or the trial you know because it's this
incredible story of this guy kind of
searching for meaning and justice in
this horrible construction of fakeness
and and and lies and and
and then treachery and and with these
awful villains populating the landscape
and and of course he's never quite able
to get there you know to find happiness
and truth and invalidation it's just
those those books are incredible to me I
think they're the last for another 100
200 years well let's go back to 2009 in
your book the great derangement you
write in there that we were really
losing faith in our political and
national institutions at that point yeah
now this is something that that I saw a
long time ago and worried about a lot
that there was a trend on both the left
and the right and unfortunately in
America we have to use these
catchphrases like left and right because
there's no other shorthand for our
politics I think it's inaccurate
sometimes we have to but what people
were increasingly I think tuning out the
quote-unquote mainstream media they were
going and seeking out their own stranger
sometimes more conspiratorial media
sources the Internet is an incredible
invention but one of the things that's
also really good at doing is matching
people with their opinions right so when
people read the news these days instead
of just turning on ABC CBS or NBC like
they did in there in the 70s now they
can kind of craft their own realities
they can say well these are the five
publications that describe the world in
a way that I agree with and they go onto
the internet and they read those five
things and that's how they get their
news and I think what started to happen
at the end of the you know the 2000s was
that people were beginning to retreat
into their own camps and they
increasingly didn't have a common set of
facts that we were debating and that
that I think was the precursor to this
election where we just couldn't agree on
what the facts were is that a negative
yeah I think so I think I think it's a
it's a bad thing it's a bad thing when
when the entire society can't even agree
on the terms of an argument right I mean
we don't really debate each other you
know on issues or policies anymore we we
disagree on the literal facts of the
argument and and that is a very
difficult place for us to be if we can't
even agree on what happened then it
becomes very very difficult for people
to come to any kind of rap rush mom
about you know anything more substance
than that and this has been going on for
a while now and I think it's a result of
the sort of fracturing of the media
landscape which is only getting more and
more fractured as time goes on I think I
think you know now you rarely see a news
organization that tries to reach the
entire population we we go demographic
hunting now is what we do
we say you know here are here are our
readers or viewers and we're going to
craft the news for that audience and
they're going to love us and these
people won't and that's unfortunate and
in fact in a recent rolling stone column
the title of it you wrote Roger Ailes
was one of the worst Americans ever yeah
well I was trying to the rider Ailes ed
and getting back to Hunter Thompson I
was I was thinking about his famous
obituaries of Nixon which you know an
obituary in Kent can be a really
interesting thing to write and I always
remembered what he said about Nixon that
he was so crooked that he needed
servants to help on one screw his pants
in the morning but so I was trying to do
something similar for Roger Ailes but
Roger Ailes you know to me was was a
main driver of this phenomenon of let's
let's let's target a demographic let's
give them news that they like and let's
forget about these other people over
here and they you know he talked about
it he said but my my audience is age
fifty fifty-five to dead you know they
don't even want to hear about you know
working women or liberals they just
don't want to exist and they crafted a
news program that was for that audience
and that that started us down the road
of this divided media landscape I think
where we're basically looking
were a population that's split into
camps and we each have our own news
sources and we don't agree on anything
and I think he was a pioneer and that
and that factor but mentally to go back
to the what you called the 70s and when
we all listened to the same news was it
good that NBC ABC and CBS essentially in
many ways controlled what we heard what
we thought no I mean look it was a it
was an information monopoly you know I
read manufacturing consent when I was a
young person and I totally agree with
with with the premise of the book which
is that it's very easy to control the
opinions of the population if you only
have a few a few media sources and they
were almost entirely Sympatico they were
always in line with the policy
objectives of the kind of permanent
government of the United States and all
that stuff it was tremendously negative
it wasn't diverse you know I mean I I
grew up in the media my father was in
the media and you know it was a very
different kind of news landscape the
only thing I'm saying I would say in its
favor was that day they had a different
attitude towards the purpose of the news
back then so the original conception of
how the news was supposed to work was
you know if you go back to the
Telecommunications Act of the 30s the
idea was the government would lease the
airwaves to these private companies and
in exchange these private companies were
supposed to provide a public service in
the form of meaningful news and so they
were supposed to make their money doing
you know entertainment or sports and
then News was supposed to be a loss
leader and it didn't have to be
profitable and there were they were only
there to you know in their minds to
present something that was factual and
useful to the public and even though it
was incredibly biased and and you know
led us into Wars like you know Vietnam
it and and excluded lots of voices it's
still there was a there was an urge
there to try to get the story correct
that isn't necessarily true now now I
think we're basically
crafting an entertainment product for
people and people consume the news as
the same way they consume entertainment
which is unfortunate back to the great
derangement from 2009 the derangement
that i described in this book kicked off
when americans finally figured out that
they'd been betrayed by their mainstream
political system but still failed to
abandon that old paradigm completely
yeah well it wasn't like we had a
revolution right I mean I think they
there was a frustration with people they
they didn't trust their politicians they
didn't trust the media but they didn't
have an alternative that they
particularly trusted either so there was
just a lot of kind of incoherent
frustration and anger out in the
population that was kind of looking for
an outlet and I think that left us ripe
for things like what happened last year
with Donald Trump I mean there was just
an enormous number of people who were
discontent and and they were looking for
any kind of change almost a perspective
of what the change was we saw these
amazing polls last year that two out of
three people favored a new direction and
they didn't care what the direction was
and that hugely favored somebody like
Trump he came in and he and his main
argument to people was you know whatever
you think of me I'm not I'm not what
you've experienced before
and that was you know that was very
attractive to people because you were
critical many times in your writing
about Donald Trump did people assume
that you supported Hillary Clinton well
that's yeah that's unfortunately a
consequence of how again how Americans
consume the media now arm it's assumed
that if you write something negative
about one party that you must support
the other party and this again is a
consequence of the politicized media
that you know I think that people like
Roger Ailes pioneered you know we're if
you are saying something negative about
the Clintons that therefore you must be
a conservative and and that
unfortunately is this kind of
materialist view of
of what news is as opposed to just being
you know sometimes people will have a
you know negative feelings about both
candidates or or they're just trying to
be objective and trying to call things
as they are it's not necessarily a
political act to to cover somebody in
positive or negative way from insane
clown president by the way word that the
name of that book comes up well there's
a there's a band called insane clown
posse that and I you know I was trying
to come up with something that was even
hanging around Donald Trump for a year
makes you not want to be subtle in your
marketing ideas so that was that was
just that yeah who get the drawing on
the front of insane clown president
that's Victor Yuhas he's the illustrator
for Rolling Stone he and eyes that he's
amazing he and I haven't worked together
for you know over a decade now and yes
is the same basically disturbed sense of
humor that I do so it's we had a lot of
fun during the campaign and from that
book
the Clintons probably should have left
politics the moment they decided they
didn't care what the public thought
about how they made their money yeah
well I thought that was an amazing
detail on some of the reporting that's
come out among other things and books
like shattered they described this
moment where Hillary Clinton essentially
said when she was trying to decide
whether or not to accept what else we
turned into over a hundred million
dollars of speaking fees by taking this
tour of all the various you know banks
and big corporations she said here
they're going to write negative things
about me whatever I do right and I that
was the substance of the quote I can't
remember exactly what she said
but I think you know that's when you're
in that place as a politician and you're
basically saying it doesn't matter what
I do anymore
you know people are going to hate me
well no matter what then what that
basically means is that you in my mind
that means you're no longer really
worrying about what the public thinks
about you which i think is a dangerous
place for a politician to be
good afternoon and welcome to book TV on
c-span - this is our monthly in-depth
program this is where we invite one
author on to talk about his or her body
of work and this month from our New York
studio we have Rolling Stone
correspondent and author Matt Taibbi mr.
Taibbi is the author of several books
his first one came out in 2000 it's
called the Exile sex drugs and libel in
the new Russia spanking the donkey
dispatches from the dump season came out
in 2005 smells like dead elephants
dispatches from a rotting Empire came
out in 2007 the great derangement which
we've talked about a little bit a
terrifying true story of war politics
and religion
2009 his most recent books are grift
topia a story of bankers politicians and
the most audacious power grab in
American history 2011 the divide came
out in 2014 American injustice in the
age of the wealth gap and finally this
past year insane clown president
dispatches from the 2016 circus this is
your chance to call in and talk with mr.
Taibbi about his work about politics
here's how you can do so - 0 - is the
area codes 7 for 8 8200 for those of you
in the east and central time zone 7 4 8
8 - 0 1 if you live in the mountain and
Pacific time zones now if you can't get
through on the phone lines still want to
make a comment we've got some social
media ways for you to get through
including twitter at book TV is our
twitter handle if you send a tweet and
use that we'll be able to see it and
maybe use it you can also make a comment
on our Facebook page facebook.com slash
book TV if you go to go down you'll see
a piece there with mr. Taibbi and you
can just make a comment underneath there
and we'll get those comments on the air
as well and finally you can send an
email to book TV at c-span dot o-r-g and
we'll begin taking those calls in just a
few minutes
mr. ket how did you get into this
business well it's it's the family
business actually my father almost
everybody on you growing up as a
reporter my my father was a news
reporter starting from the age of 18 and
that's Mike Tate Mike type yeah he
worked here in New York at WCBS and WNBC
for a long time he's just sort of
retiring now he does a little work for
PBS but he was in the business for 50
years my stepmother was an anchor at CNN
for a while
business anchor hey what's pretty in
Beverly shook and a lot of you know my
family friends growing up they worked in
places like the International Herald
Tribune and so my childhood was
basically like the movie anchorman you
know I spent most of my formative years
and you know local television affiliates
with you know guys with bad facial hair
and stuff like that so I I actually
never wanted to do this for a living but
I wanted to be a novelist but when I
turned out that my fiction was was
pretty bad I sort of fell back into the
family business and and I've been here
ever since when did you know you were a
writer I always wanted to be a writer uh
from the age of maybe 11 or 12 I think
you know that was never a question in my
mind I had a really deep love of books
when I was growing up I was an only
child we moved a lot books were you know
a tremendous solace to me you know um
you know I was depressed a lot and then
you know I when I started to learn how
to write I became really obsessed with
the idea you know writing is almost like
a religion if you really get into it
it's it's a you can never really
complete the task of being perfect at it
so you have to constantly try to
practice getting better and better and
better and I became really addicted to
it at a very young age I wanted to be a
comic novelist you know I my heroes were
all funny right
people like you know Saki and Nikolai
Gogol and bull caca you know the heart
of a dog and Master and Margarita looks
like that
catch-22 Evelyn wah even wah so these
were the things that I want that's what
I wanted to do when I grew up and I
spent a lot of my early you know early
years my teens start trying to do that
kind of thing and didn't work out but um
but you know journalism has been great
in a different way you know I think it's
it's the term it's an amazing profession
because it allows you to see the whole
world and meet this extraordinary range
of people and you know it's been great
in a way that probably was more
fulfilling than then sitting at home
being a fiction writer would have been
you said that you were depressed a lot
why I don't know some people are just
depressive I you know but do you think
it's organic I think it probably is yeah
I think most people who have that
problem would tell you that it's just a
chemical thing in your brain
interestingly a lot of the people who
were kind of my heroes also had the same
problem I remember reading about you
know Gogol who was a you know famous
Russian writer and he was a terrible
depressive and he conquered it by
sitting at home and trying to think of
the funniest things that he could all
day long and he would write those things
down and that that's how that's how he
got through it
and that's you know that was that was
something that I did a lot in my my teen
years I I tried to write funny stories
and things like that and that was a that
was a way of kind of me making sense of
the world on your bio it says that you
were the sports editor for The Moscow
Times how did that come about yeah so
one of my first Jobs was I was I was
living in Russia I studied in Russia in
1990-91 so I was there when it was
communist and then I was there
went home they had a revolution that I
came back and I I loved it over in
Russia so much one of the reasons
actually was that you know as we young
often depressed teenager and
twenty-something you know America was
very difficult place for me too because
there's enormous pressure in America to
be successful and happy and you turn on
the television everyone has perfect
teeth and they're all you know thrilled
and Russia everybody was depressed you
know when I when I got there people were
drab but nobody had nice clothes and and
I thought I fit right in here this is
perfect you know so I when I went to
study there I just didn't come home and
before long I ended up needing a job and
so I started stringing for various
newspapers and and sooner or later I
ended up meeting people in Moscow they
had an expatriate newspaper there and
since I had a sports background they
gave me the Sports Editors job so that's
how I did that
how did you end up playing professional
basketball in Mongolia so I I had played
basketball in college in the States
you know for for Bard College here in
New York yeah I'm an okay you know
Division for a basketball player
basically and and I was I played a lot
of Street qualen but in Moscow and I was
out at Moscow State University one day
and I met this kid we were playing a
game for round three and he told me he
was one Basara which is the capital of
Mongolia and he told me about a league
they had there the NBA the Mongolian
Basketball Association he said it was
the only league in the world that had
NBA rules outside of America and and it
just sounded so like so much fun I went
into work the next day and quit my job
and I packed up my stuff I got in the
trans-siberian railroad rule and bought
her and when I got there I got a tryout
and got on one of the teams and I would
have stayed there for a long time I was
really having a great time because I got
quite ill and I ended up having to come
home but you know it was cool I was like
a you know a sports star there and you
know people would recognize me on the
streets and stuff it was it was great I
was caught I was known as the Mongol
Rodman believe it or not Matt baby it's
been written about you've written about
your drug use and why is that important
for us to know I don't know if it's
important for anybody to know I just
didn't particularly feel you need to
deny it I think you know I had a period
there in Russia we had a newspaper
called the exile which was like a
nightlife guide and you know we were
young and it in a town that was very
much like the Wild West
you know communism but just collapsed it
was it was crazy at the time and you
know we were doing a lot of crazy things
and I did have a pretty serious drug
problem at one point and yeah I thought
that I particularly want anybody to know
about it but when I guess what somebody
I saw I admit to it you know you've been
with Rolling Stone since 2005 your book
grift topia came out in 2011 and in that
book you write that Alan Greenspan's
rise to the top is one of the great
scams of our time yeah so Alan Greenspan
was a character I originally had planned
on doing this the 2,000 word a little
section on him because he was so
important to the whole history of the
modern financial services industry is
his attitude you know he has the this
philosophy that's parado a lot from Iran
you know he was an acolyte of hers and
he was fascinating to me as a character
because he was very famous for being
this great predictor of economic events
but when I actually went back and looked
it turned out that he had been wrong but
almost everything that he'd ever
predicted and and so he was mostly you
know sort of like a lot of famous
hangers-on and you know who hang around
rock bands or other celebrities he was
famous for being somebody who was really
good at telling politicians what they
wanted to hear
and and that that gift of being like a
president whisper I think really was
what allowed him to serve in the
capacity that he did for so long it
wasn't that he was at so great in
economists he really wasn't it was just
more that he was a very skilled
politician and and that was what I was
trying to demonstrate in that book and
the divide came out in 2014 in the end
the one bank to get thrown on the dock
was not a Wall Street firm but one
housed in the opposite direction a
little to the north a tiny family-owned
community bank in Chinatown called
abacus Federal Savings Bank yeah in fact
there's a movie out about it now called
abacus Maul enough to jail this is an
amazing and incredible story because
this it's a tiny family-owned Chinese
immigrant Bank in Chinatown it's stuck
between two noodle shops and it was the
only bank in America to be indicted
after the financial crisis and they were
indicted because of a series of very
small impropriety that they themselves
reported to the authorities and there
was they were eventually uh prosecuted
for defrauding Fannie Mae but Fannie Mae
never suffered a single cent of loss in
any of those transactions so what I was
trying to show in that book was you know
here you have this tiny regional bank
that's surrounded by all these behemoths
financial institutions that later
settled for billions of dollars for
committing crimes on massive scales far
beyond what advocates had ever did but
none of them were criminally prosecuted
and that was because we have this new
doctrine in America which is too big to
get too big to fail and too big to jail
we have openly said people like former
attorney general or Eric Holder have
said that you know that they were
reluctant to prosecute certain companies
because they were worried about the
clinical collateral consequences and
what that might do to the larger economy
and so you know the converse of that is
if we're
if we're afraid to prosecute a big bank
because we're concerned that it's going
to upset the economy well that means
that there's certain you have to be
small enough to be able to prosecute
alright and so that's what that's what
happened in the case of advocates they
found a bank that was just small small
enough to prosecute and so they indicted
them but very recently they were were
all found not guilty and and so it's an
amazing story and I highly recommend
everybody watch the movie - it's an
uplifting story
well July 9 2013 you were in the
courtroom when Cyrus Vance jr. was the
prosecutor and essentially these people
were marched through in Chains right
yeah yeah and some of them that are
actually already been arraigned and they
brought them back a second time for a
photo op you think about this like you
know not one of the major bankers
whoever who got in trouble or who were
accused of wrongdoing after 2008 none of
them had to appear so much as the appear
in a courtroom you know all of these big
deals between you know the settlements
between companies like JPMorgan Chase
and Goldman Sachs they were all done in
backrooms and there was just a you know
an exchange of money nobody had to sit
in the dock nobody had to be publicly
humiliated but when you had this small
immigrant Bank they needed a photo
opportunity so what do they do they
indicted a bunch of people and they
literally got them in a chain gang and
drag them into the courtroom and you
know view the excuse the prosecutors
gave later was that that wasn't up to us
that was up to the bailiffs in the
courthouse but clearly it was a
political thing and and it was then and
the the purpose of telling that story
was to show that the economy and how we
treat different kinds of people you know
when we're talking about a a group of
people who don't have power influence or
connections we treat them one way and
when they do have connections you know
they never see the inside of a courtroom
it I sensed a feeling of outrage on your
part reading oh yeah of course of course
then I said and I think outrage is an
important component of being a reporter
I mean I think if you if you aren't in
touch with what outrageous then it's
very difficult to do this job
and yeah and you have to maintain your
sense of that throughout the years one
of the things that happens to people who
who are in the press for a long long
time is to get outraged fatigued after a
while you've seen so much horrible stuff
and so much bad behavior that you stop
responding to things in the way that a
normal person would and that's that's
something you have to guard against so
as you get as you get older you know
this feeling of you know I've seen that
before you have to continually say this
is not acceptable you know and and find
ways to get upset about it from the
divide we have a profound hatred of the
weak in the poor and a corresponding
grovelling terror before the rich and
successful and were building a
bureaucracy to match those findings yeah
what what I was trying to say there was
that the underlying political what what
drives the policies that lead to mass
incarceration to you know things like
stop and frisk community policing where
we're stopping
five hundred thousand six hundred
thousand people a year emptying their
pockets and throwing people in jail for
a nickel bags and dime bags on the one
hand and then we take people like HSBC
you know one of the world's largest
banks that gets caught laundering 800
million dollars for narco terrorists and
you know Central and South America and
you know we don't even prosecute those
people they they you know they just pay
a fine and walk away I think that what's
underlying the the policy divide there
is that we we feel like X group of
people we we worship the people who make
money we we have a reverence and
admiration for people who are quote
unquote wealth creators and the people
who we see as parasites and nuisances
well you know we have no sympathy for
them whatsoever they belong in jail you
know I had an experience that was really
eye-opening for me during while I was
writing that book and I asked a
prosecutor in Washington I said how can
you let these guys who laundered eight
hundred million dollars in drug money
how can you let them walk and not go to
jail if we're sending people to jail for
possession you know on the other hand
these guys got to go sit in jail and
what he said to me was have you been to
a prison those places are dangerous you
know and he didn't mean it in an ironic
way what do you what he was really
trying to say without without really you
know admitting it was I just don't see
that kind of offender as deserving jail
you know no matter what he or she does
but these offenders will you know they
grow up in these bad neighborhoods and
they're used to that kind of thing so so
of course we send them to jail and
that's that's what I was trying to get
it this psychological split that we have
where we we just have this hidden
hostility towards people who you know
are poor and without means and we we
fear and revere these other people and
it not to go on about this too much but
you know I had an experience in Russia
that was that was that gave me some
insight into this when I was in a
student in the Soviet Union when I went
to school in the morning I would see
these these kids selling blue jeans and
rabbit hats and stuff like that and of
course that was commerce so that was
against the law in communist Russia and
every now and then those kids would
disappear for three or four weeks you
know they do a little bit in jail and
and they would come back meanwhile the
people they were selling to you know
they would sell socks and t-shirts and
clothes to the you know the party
members who were the the running the
school nobody ever did anything to them
and that was because in it was so
ingrained in Soviet society that the
party members don't get in trouble but
these people do get in trouble and I
think that kind of unspoken split is
where we are as a country and it's just
hard to reconcile with it's a class
plant it's yeah I think it's a class
split it goes beyond that to though I
mean I think clearly race is a huge
factor also you know I think I think
white audiences probably wouldn't want
to admit it but they would look
differently at you know
you know a poor black person who gets
busted with you know vagal weed in his
or her pocket than they would awake it
gets closer for the same thing they
would say oh he's just going through a
phase you know is what they would say
you know all kids kids will be kids but
you know they would they would say
something very different you know about
a black kid who gets pulled over and has
drugs found them so I think you know
it's racist classes all those things
before we leave the divide you also
visited California and went through
their welfare system right what was that
experience well I mean again what I was
trying to show is use a lot of the the
big banks and financial companies that
had covered a lot of them are
technically guilty of crimes like fraud
right you know I would talk to
whistleblowers and things like that and
it explained to me like look if you
wanted to prosecute these people here's
the statute they're guilty of right it
was a fee like some kind of fraud
statute so I looked at how they treated
those people and then I wanted to see
how they treated people who committed
crimes like welfare fraud and what that
experience was like was you know I would
talk to people who are on welfare and
they would tell me stories about how
you'd have to fill up this gigantic sort
of complex of forms just to get the aid
in the first place and then what they
would do is they would check every
single item that you entered every click
on a monthly basis and they had you know
this whole network of computers is
constantly searching your record and if
there's any inconsistency at all they
automatically generate a fraud case and
you will either be prosecuted for it or
you'll have your benefits taken away
your family's benefits will be taken
away it can enter your home at any time
there's a Supreme Court case that says
that they can do that you know if once
you're taking public aid so I was just
trying to show that again this dichotomy
and how we treat people like you can't
you couldn't just go and you know seize
the books of a company that's committed
you know fraud like a mortgage subprime
mortgage fraud they would treat them
very differently than they would treat
somebody who committed welfare fraud and
it would punish them much more severely
for the welfare fraud than for the 100
million dollar fraud so I was just
trying to show how even getting that aid
is
constant struggle to avoid being
prosecuted for misusing the funds
whereas you know people who enjoy the
large F's for instance of the you know
the the Federal Reserve you know banking
window they're borrowing billions of
dollars a month these gigantic banks you
know the government doesn't do anything
there is no surveillance or anything
like that in that area so again I was
just trying to show that the differing
attitudes towards these two classes of
people you hear from your Rolling Stone
readers oh yeah absolutely yeah and and
I hear some people on Twitter and and I
make it a point to read you know if
anybody writes hate mail or a critical
letter if somebody takes the time to
actually sit down and write me a letter
I always read it I think it's important
to me your hate your hating tale not
everybody does it I don't block anybody
on social media I think often you know
you need that's one of the ways you get
better as a writer as you listen to your
readers and sometimes they tell you you
know this thing that you tried didn't
work it wasn't funny it's okay and you
have to listen to that so Matt ad is it
easy or is it is one susceptible to
being brought into the group think when
you're traveling on a campaign and
you're in this bubble with other
reporters
is there a groupthink susceptibility
absolutely yeah I mean it's it's a
social thing it's a class thing again
just to talk about the differences
between when I was a kid and around the
people who my father worked with you
know reporting was more like a trade
than a profession back then there were a
lot of people who are in the press who
didn't go to college you know they went
they were like this they they got in
sort of via the seymour hersh method you
know they would become it would be copy
boys at age 16 and they would just work
their way through and it was it was a
job more like being a plumber or a you
know an electrician than it was like
being a doctor or a lawyer
and the back then I think those people
didn't have any affinity for politicians
or the rich they were they tended to
have this kind of like ticket to the man
attitude of course they were it was a
far less diverse group of people on one
hand but they you know in terms of class
they were very much more working-class
group of people back in the day now when
you're on the campaign plane you see a
lot of people who are like me they come
from privileged backgrounds they went to
really good schools there they tend to
be white and well-off and they get into
this business very often because they're
attracted to the idea of being near
power and powerful people they want to
hang out after the speech with you know
the candidate days or the or the
candidate is or herself and you would
never seen that early or 40 years ago
this desire to be behind the rope line
with with a politician back then the
politician was kind of the enemy you
know and what I've definitely seen
lately is that socially the media and
the people they're covering are the same
people you know after the campaigns are
over they hang out with each other you
know the political strategists and the
aides and the pollsters they go to the
same bars and happens more again and the
Upper West Side and I don't know that
that's a healthy thing I mean it's it's
it may be it may not be but it's
certainly different from what it used to
be in your book insane clown president
you're very critical of the mannequin
what happened oh the Hillary Clinton the
mannequin video yeah I mean I think that
might have been a little gratuitous you
know at the time this was right after
the election I wrote that and I remember
looking at that the mannequin challenge
I think they called it right and it was
a bunch of people who were on the plane
together and it was press
the the clintons AIDS and the Clintons
and I think Jon Bon Jovi was on that in
that shot as well and what happens again
when you're in that environment for a
long time it becomes romanticized hey
we're all in this adventure together you
know isn't it cool that we're all
hanging out hang out together and there
are celebrities in the plane and we're
all friends and that congenial
atmosphere you can you see it and looks
like primary colors right or movies like
that where it's just this they kind of
lionized the whole idea of the roving
campaign but they were you know they
there was this disaster looming all
outside the plane and they were
completely unaware of it of it happening
I mean they they probably all should
have been panicking instead of playing
that goofy goofy game I don't know I
mean it I I've had it it's not exclusive
to the Clintons I've seen that kind of
thing in a couple of different campaigns
I was in a plane in the Obama campaign
once where I came in and I noticed that
there all the reporters had photos had
taken photos of themselves with Barack
Obama and then posted it on the you know
that would stick them on the side of the
plane in the press section and you know
I like Barack Obama I voted for him but
you know I thought that was kind of a
bad look for us you know we didn't want
to be acting like groupies you know even
just just superficially it looked bad
you know and so I I think that's what I
was trying to get to you with that
mannequin challenges you know we even if
we even if we do like the people we're
hanging out with in the plane we have to
kind of pretend at least that we're
separate you know maintain that distance
because it's a bad look when we get
caught you know making a mistake like we
made in this in this race we got it
entirely wrong from start to finish and
that's bad for us in your columns you've
also been critical of Tom Friedman the
New York Times columnist yeah I mean I
actually kind of enjoy reading Tom
Friedman I mean what I've really gotten
after with Tom Friedman is
his writing style you know he's he's
famous for mixing metaphors and some of
them are so strange that it's almost
like a psychedelic experience try to
follow it what he's trying to say you
know he'll yeah like he he compared once
the Iraq war to driving a car with no
steering wheel he's like sometimes you
just have to throw the wheel out you
know and but you can't drive a car with
no steering wheel you know what I mean
or he'll stay on you know he has a
famous thing the rule of holes he says
you know when you're in when you're in a
hole that's too deep
you should stop when you're in three
holes you should stop digging like you
can't be in three holes at once you know
and there's all these bizarre images
that are kind of mismatched in his
writing and I actually really enjoy
writing it and I met him once and he was
very gracious to me and I feel I felt
really bad about saying negative things
about him so it's not directed at him as
a person I just find his writing really
interesting what's the origin of the
name Toby Taibbi is a um it's a Sicilian
name of Arabic origin I'm neither of
those things my father is adopted
he is Filipino and Hawaiian and he was
adopted by a Sicilian family here in New
York and so that's where that name comes
from Matt Taibbi is our guest
Rolling Stone correspondent and author
his most recent book is insane clown
president here's what the cover looks
like phone numbers to dial in two zero
two seven four eight eighty two hundred
if you live in the eastern central time
zone two zero two seven four eight eight
two zero one for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific and Tyler in
Marietta Georgia you've been very
patient you are on the air Tyler go
ahead I'm not easier not to me you feel
complicit in the Paris attacks the
immediate is acting as you know the
propaganda arm for the terrorists by
providing an onslaught coverage of their
attacks and why doesn't the media get
this I know they're probably doing it is
you want to generate more you know
we're readings and generate more profits
and what are your thoughts on this
that's an interesting question Tyler I
hadn't thought about it from that point
of view clearly terrorism doesn't work
if nobody sees it so on the one hand
there is it's probably some truth to
that but on the other hand it would be
hugely responsible not to cover these
things at the same time so I don't I
don't know exactly what the happy medium
is there you know there may be a way to
do it that's less sensational then then
the way that we do do it certainly you
know more people die in domestic murders
overwhelmingly than they do in terrorist
attacks but we worry a lot more about
terrorism on the news so that's that's
definitely a you know a consideration
but yeah clearly yeah I wouldn't
necessarily say that we're complicit in
it I just think it's it's probably
there's probably a way that we could
deal with that
that wouldn't wouldn't quite amplify the
effect that they're looking for quite as
much because to be frank people are so
scared of terrorists now that they've
made some crazy political decisions as a
result you know dating back to 9/11 and
a lot of that has to do with the nut
sort of bombardment of coverage that you
get whenever there was a terrorist
attack so yeah that's a good point
do you find yourself when things like
what happened has it been happening in
London do you find yourself turning on
the TV immediately I don't you know
again I lived in Moscow when Paris
attacks were pretty routine the Chechens
were kind of routinely bombing the city
I'd just missed being in a subway
bombing a couple of times actually and
you know I don't I don't find that it's
something that I have to glue myself to
the television to watch it's a fact of
life I you know I think it's a very
complicated political dilemma but
you know getting myself worked up about
it is I don't think it's helpful so you
know but it clearly there is something
to the to duty to the idea that scaring
people is a way to get them to tune in
to your network and terrorists are scary
so there there is a commercial motive
there and you know it might be worth
unpacking that a little bit well I can't
find which book or article it is but you
have a quote saying that the best story
for CNN is somebody has fallen down the
well and the best story for Fox is that
somebody was pushed down the well by a
radical Muslim terror right yeah exactly
yeah good point I was trying to make
there is that both the formula for in
the liberal media and the conservative
media it's the same formula we're both
looking for the same kind of
sensationalist stories it's just that
the the Fox version tends to be you know
tilted in a direction if they can manage
it you know that their favorite story
will tend to involve some kind of you
know political nemesis whether it's you
know a liberal professor or or an
Islamic terrorist or you know God knows
who else but yeah exactly
next call from Matt Taibbi comes from
Nancy and Redondo Beach California hi
Nancy hi good morning guys thank you
Peter so much and thanks for c-span and
Matt I've followed you for a very long
time and my question is that my sense is
when a journalist or a reporter is going
to write a story or a book most the time
it's to kind of confirm what they
already believe and they may ignore what
they don't want to see or contradicts
what they initially believed and I'm
wondering for you personally has there
been a time where you thought when you
into a story and you thought it was
going to be one way and it turned out to
be completely different
and is it possible for recorders and
journalists I'll take my answer off the
air and thanks again Thank You Nancy
yes thank you that's a great question on
into the last part first no I believe
that everybody all coverage is biased I
don't think you can have
I think objectivity in the way that they
teach you in journals in school is kind
of a myth because every every decision
you make editorially speaks to your
point of view on things so just to take
an example even if you're looking at the
New York Times and they're covering
something in that kind of unemotional
third-person voice and they're trying to
give equal weight to different points of
view but even even the choice of whether
to put something on the front page or in
them in the middle on the top of the
page or at the bottom whether to have a
picture or not a picture hat whether to
make the headline a scare headline or
less threatening all those things speak
to they're all editorial decisions and
they all speak to what your opinion on
the subject is so I think there's always
bias and there are a lot of different
ways to handle it I try to be just sort
of open about it and when I'm covering
something I'll say this is what I think
about the subject in terms of the other
thing about the confirmation bias which
is the sort of the second problem that
is a huge issue in our business because
among other things now speed is such a
factor in and how the commercial media
works you have to you have to be as
quick as possible in generating your
content and one of the ways you do that
is by knowing what you're going to say
beforehand you know you if you're going
to do a story on let's say middle-class
white suburban Heights who left the
Republican Party - so the traditional
Republican Party - vote for Donald Trump
well what you'll do is you'll go to an
event you'll look for people like that
you'll ask them leading questions that
tend to confirm your thesis and then as
soon as you get those quotes you just
dump them in the story and and you
publish it and that's that's not a good
way to do business I think it's much
better to enter into a subject in a way
that's open-ended and that allows you
the freedom to got to go in a different
direction I've definitely had the
experience of of covering a story and
thinking it was going to be one thing
and
and having it turn out to be something
completely different
I've had the experience of expecting
somebody to be guilty of something when
I started investigating and having it
turned out that they weren't and had to
abandon the story you have to have the
freedom to not write to that's another
important thing and a lot of reporters
don't have that freedom so yeah I think
that's that's kind of a key thing
unfortunately again because of the way
our business is structured it's just
really hard to allow reporters the
latitude to to kind of go where the
facts leave them as opposed to just
cranking out content let's hear from
Phyllis in Brooklyn New York ifeliz hi I
have a question about health care
specifically the members of Congress
what kind of health care do they have
how much is their deductible and their
copay do their plans cover abortion and
birth control
how old are their children on their
health plans how long do they keep these
health plans is for life and who funds
their health plan that's right I think
that's a great question I actually don't
know the answer to that I do know that
they the members of Congress do enjoy a
federal health insurance program or at
least they did up until very recently a
lot until the last time I covered the
health insurance story so yeah we're
paying for their health insurance and
and that of course adds to the
perversity of members of Congress moving
to take away health insurance from
people so but I think that information
is easily discoverable if you just go on
the internet and look for it this is an
email question from floor F lor in
California with your experience in the
former Soviet Union what's your take on
the current Putin Trump bromance and
subversion of the US political system if
Trump or a Democratic president might he
be tarred and feathered by the right
also what similarities did you find
between the Russian and American
national
characters so what's your tape first of
all yeah well so you know I've taken a
little bit of heat for this for being
kind of a skeptic on this Russia story
and you know my concern with this story
is not first of all I'm politically I
think it's pretty clear I'm not a big
fan of Donald Trump you know I certainly
wouldn't shut it here if you were in
each but my concern about the Russia
story is that it's been very sloppily
reported it's been reported in a way
that lends its people to excesses just
to give you an example you know the the
steel dossier that was released you know
responsible news outlet would ever touch
that
and when BuzzFeed published that it set
in motion a chain of events that I think
was very unfortunate because we you know
as a as reporters we you know we as a
rule don't publish unverifiable
accusations of crimes against people for
the simple reason that we wouldn't want
that to happen to it to us and so when
we did this with Trump with this dossier
that had this explosive set of
allegations in it but was totally
unverifiable you know now it's all over
the Internet and it's the you know we
have millions and millions of people who
sort of believe implicitly that this
this thing is true and it's led to you
know audience having audiences coming to
news stories about this with a set of
expectations they already believe a
certain set of facts has been confirmed
when you know we don't know for a fact
exactly what happens what's happened
this story I spent months on this and
this is an example of what I was just
talking about about not writing when you
can't find you know what the truth is I
every time I tried to actually get hold
of something concrete with this story I
just kept coming up with dead ends and
supposition Xand anonymous sources who
who wouldn't you know come up with
verifiable concrete information so I
worry a lot about the story I think it's
the it could be a disaster for our
system of media if this turns out not to
be true and I just worry that we're
getting in over our skis with this thing
you say you've gotten the treatment
though from others
yeah well and then and this is one of
the things that I worry about which is
when when people are emotional enough
about a story that they attack somebody
or there's a new term out there for
people who don't believe the Russia
thing they call them anti anti Trumper
right and so this what they're accusing
people of is basically aiding and
abetting Donald Trump where the Russians
you know I've been accused of being a
Russian agent you know because among
other things because I lived in Russia
for a long time but what happens when
people see that happening to people like
me and even though I may not worry about
that criticism other people might and no
and they will think twice about about
saying well I'm not sure about this you
know and when it silences people and and
that's not a positive thing people
become afraid to speak their minds and
and it these stories generate a momentum
everybody knows it that it's easy to get
hits and followers on Twitter by fueling
this thing and then they know that the
opposite will happen if they express any
skepticism about this thing and that's
not a positive situation you don't want
people being afraid to say what they see
you know and and the media in particular
I saw this starting to happen last year
before this Russia thing even took place
there was a a shift and even there are
even people like Jim Ruttenberg in the
New York Times who wrote about this
openly they said
Trump is such an extreme character he's
such a threat that we in the media have
to rethink our traditional kind of
objective posture towards things and
start to become advocates and start to
think of ourselves as a way as a force
that will stop him and I think a lot of
people in our business have adopted that
attitude and what's dangerous about that
attitude is that it it undercuts our
power institutionally in the media the
media derives its power entirely from
its independence if we are seen as being
part of the Democratic Party or part of
a resistance effort that a is one party
over another then we completely lose our
legitimacy we have to be seen as only
being about one thing and that's the
truth right and when we're seeing about
as being about something else then
then we're useless to people we don't
have any real function in society we
have to be separate it's kind of like
when you know the Senate in order to
help Barack Obama push through his
nominees they you know they they got rid
of their ability to filibuster
presidential nominees a couple years ago
because they wanted to you know end the
gridlock in Washington and that seemed
like a great idea to progresses at the
time right because it helped people get
through and do their work but look what
happened three years later now the
Senate is too weak the minority party
can't filibuster the Trump's nominees
and the Senate undercut itself it
undercut its own institutional authority
on behalf of somebody else in the media
I think is doing that now we by signing
on with this kind of resistance effort
and making us indistinguishable from
that effort we're losing our power and
we have to be seen as being separate and
that's what I worry about
fluor another part of his or her
question was differences or similarities
Russian and American characters well
there are a lot of there there are a lot
of differences and a lot of similarities
I think both countries students
they're citizens view themselves as you
know as superpower nations and they
derive incredible pride in the idea that
they're different from people who live
in small countries that don't affect
everything on the on in the world there
was a I remember being in the apartment
of a Russian teacher on the day that
they dismantled the Soviet map and they
changed the name from the USSR to the
the CIS the I forget what the that even
stands for in English but basically the
the old Soviet map became much smaller
it was as if the United States became
you know 23 States instead of 50 and he
looked at the new map and he was crying
you know because he had grown up his
whole life with this gigantic 11 time
zones expanse of a superpower and he
thought of himself as part of this
empire and now he wasn't anymore you
know and I think Americans and Russians
both share that idea that we are part of
the sort of deciding cadre and in the
world hierarchy you know both countries
are heavily militarized they tend to be
much more macho than other countries and
you know in terms of differences in I
don't know that's a long list you know
Americans are much more conservative I
would say I don't know it I'll have to
think about that one give me a little
bit of time on that well while you're
thinking about that Matt Taibbi let's
hear from Walter in Cincinnati hi Walter
go ahead with your question or comment
hi Matt I like to have that well first
of all I think that you're absolutely
right that the media has become a
mouthpiece for the Democratic Party but
that's another thing what I wanted to
know is your opinion of the writing of
Ali Hirsi Ali who has written a book I
think it's called a heretic her notion
is that we will never eliminate the
jihadists by trying to kill them all
what we need to do is support the notion
of the Islamic world having a
Reformation similarly too similar to
what the Christian Church did back which
they have to get out of being in the
seventh century and your opinion of that
and why that is not talked about I don't
see it on any television nobody is
talking about the idea of having the
Islamic world having a Reformation
thanks
all right that's Walter in Cincinnati
are you familiar with her she Ali I'm
not I haven't read her CD Ali's book you
know the only thing I would say that
Walter is yeah I have spent a lot of
time in the Middle East I clearly don't
agree with the idea of that killing them
all is going to solve any kind of
problem I think that we exacerbate the
problem when we do that this is a an
issue that has I agree has to come from
a transformation within those societies
and it probably also has something to do
with you know changing our attitudes
towards those societies I think that we
would we wouldn't have those all of
those those problems if we hadn't had
such a powerful and intrusive colonial
presence and a lot of those places for
for so long and hadn't had an interest
in their oil wealth and other issues so
it's it's a it's a definitely a
complicated issue but for sure you know
dropping bombs from is not to be the way
to go this is a tweet from Alan could
you comment on the phenomenon of buyer's
remorse as it relates to voters who
supported from uh well I haven't seen a
whole lot of data on how many people
have have that buyer's remorse oh I have
seen that Trump's approval rating is now
down around 39% which is of course lower
than a little bit lower than where he
was in November but the Democrats have
also seen a significant drop in their
approval rating since November they were
at forty five and they're there now
40 so I you know I think people who
voted for Donald Trump if they weren't
turned off to him before November
they're probably not going to be turned
off to him to him I mean it would take
something extraordinary elect proof of
him conspiring with Vladimir Putin or or
some very very awful sexual scandal or
something like that to really get people
to move off their supported him so it's
it's like fandom you know you did you
know how many people you know are you
know Minnesota Vikings fans who suddenly
stopped being Minnesota Vikings fans
that's the way politics is in America
now you
it's a fanatical kind of relationship in
a lot of many cases and it's hard to
break that bond Matt Taibbi you live up
here in New York City and you write for
Rolling Stone
what's been the general attitude of your
neighbors and friends and people in the
city so it's Donald Trump well almost
everybody I know is horrified by Donald
Trump and and even the the dichotomy is
not that hard to figure out where it is
in America if you look at the map almost
everybody lives in a big city votes
Democrat and everybody who lives in
between the big cities what's Republican
I mean the maps are incredible it's it's
seas of red with little dots of blue all
over the country we're really two
different countries right now and we see
the world entirely differently in if you
travel in one circle you're not going to
run into a whole lot of Trump supporters
I certainly don't and again that
probably contributes to why we didn't
see it coming you know I think most of
the people who work in the media they're
like me they live in the you are Kelly
in Washington for the most part they
they like shows like the wire and you
know the Americans and you know they and
they watch movies with subtitles and
they you know eat death Nick food and
that's how they you know they don't
watch NASCAR it's a cultural difference
so yeah I think it's going to be very
tough for those two Americas to to
have any kind of you know exchange with
each other did you have any friends or
family members that were Trump
supporters that just shocked you well I
do I have some family members to our
Trump supporters but you know they've
been conservatives for quite a long time
so I there are a couple of people who I
know who who didn't vote this time and
that was a little bit shocking who and
that that I think spoke to some
frustration probably with the Democratic
Party because these were lifelong
Democrats who aren't going Democratic
anymore but in terms of people who I
suddenly became Trump supporters know I
don't know anybody like that you this is
an email from Mansur Johnson in Tucson
Arizona Matt in your recent article on
Goldman Sachs purchase of certificates
issued by Venezuela for thirty two cents
on the dollar you referred to Venezuelan
president Maduro as a dictator
I was shocked you as a progressive
journalist would use the word dictator
the same characterization of the
Venezuelan president that elements in
the US government have used ever since
Chavez yeah I heard some pushback on
that from some people you know I haven't
lived in South America I'm relying on
people that I know who who cover South
American politics than you write to me
from South America you know my
understanding of that situation is you
know that he essentially cancelled
elections and and as you know has been
acting in an undemocratic way but you
know I admit that there's room for me to
learn on that issue so you don't have to
go back and look Barry is calling in
from Scottsdale Arizona and Barry you're
on book TV with Matt Taibbi iMacs how
you doing how are you doing good I'm
doing great thanks thanks for being on
the show too two questions a little bit
off the beaten path not really one
is how big we're sinking how did we get
from presidential candidate like Gary
Hart thoughtful reflective to Donald
Trump seems like a huge leap to me
secondly second question is what's your
take on President Obama you know I heard
you say you voted for him I voted for
him too but you know a number of
problems were facing now were allowed to
fester under his administration for
eight years he really didn't deal with
them I mean their cereal there's the
racial divide in the country which is as
bad as it's ever been
Isis he was I don't know if he was
afraid to deal with them or whatever
what's your take I really liked him as a
human being but I just don't know as a
president if he really did anything
what's your take on those two issues
thank you I listen no thanks
well I wrote a piece about Obama right
after the election and you know I I had
been critical of Barack Obama in the
last eight years mainly because on the
subject that I have covered throughout
most of his presidency which is
corruption in the financial services
sector you know he doesn't have a great
record there his administration was
mainly known for not taking not winning
a single conviction against any senior
level executive for any of the
corruption that led to the 2008
financial crisis and so because that was
my little bailiwick I you know I was I
was critical of Barack Obama I didn't
like the fact that he no he ran as an
economic progressive and then when he
got elected he brought in a whole bunch
of people from Citigroup basically to
run his transition team and you know
people like Timothy Geithner and Eric
Holder were you know and lanny breuer
who was the assistant attorney general
throughout that time you know they were
corporate lawyers who had long worked
for Wall Street they had all the
different all the banks had been their
clients and that came through and a lot
of their enforcement decisions and so
just in terms of that I had always been
critical with Obama but you know upon
reflection looking back at him I think
history is going to look back on him in
a very favorable way not necessarily
because of his policy ideas because as a
progressive person I think he was a
disappointment to a lot of a lot of
people in a lot of areas whether it's
you know the continuation of Guantanamo
Bay or the the drone bombings or
whatever it was but his demeanor his his
composure and his unwillingness to to
give when to you know anger and to not
give up on whole segments of the society
I was really impressed by what he said
after the election in by way of I think
criticizing Hillary Clinton you know one
of the things he said was you know I
even in places where I knew I was going
to lose I continued to try to reach
people in rural Iowa and there were
places where I instead of losing by 50
points I only lost by 20 points and and
Obama was what he was saying it wasn't
just a strategic thing that he was
talking about I thought he was saying
basically you know we just can't give up
on being one whole country you know he
he still tried no matter how bad the
abuse directed toward him was and there
was just awful racist horrible rhetoric
you know including the birther thing he
never he never kind of took the bait and
and made it a divisive and and and
vicious and now when we have you know
somebody like Trump is president where
you know every tiny slight becomes a
Twitter war in ten seconds you know the
it's going to impact the national
character going forward for a whole
generation and I think Obama's the
example he set for young people about
how to comport yourself I think was a
really important one even if I didn't
agree with
the things that he did policy-wise so
you know looking back I do I really
admire Barack Obama I think he he
acquitted himself incredibly well in a
nearly impossible situation despite the
fact that I was disappointed in some of
his decisions next call for Matt Taibbi
comes from Diana in Lone Pine California
hi Diana hi I'm so happy that I get to
take you minute um alright my first part
is a comment and I just want to say
thank you for saying that about Roger
Ailes like I've been watching this all
this stuff back and forth on various
news channels for years and always the
level of viciousness they came from Fox
new level of fear I watched it affect my
friends and I'm older and it was like
they just became so locked areas that we
couldn't can't talk about anything like
that because I northern liberals had gal
and my and I just want to thank you for
like them helping me with my thinking
and I wasn't going loony that one person
can affect a whole nation like that like
day after day year after year just
spouting which is the reporters just
spouting such mean stuff and most the
time inaccurate but anyway the question
I want to ask you is why do we need
health insurance companies like I've had
rounds of cancer and luckily I've had
Medicare and I live because of that but
why I'm in agree as a child we just want
the doctor you know there wasn't
encourage you about insurance and so on
why do we need insurance companies that
take trillions of dollars anyways thank
you yeah no thank you thank you for the
yeah it's been a while since I've
covered that subject but I mean I
remember that he's looking at the
comparison of the cost between because
America's health coverage is by far we
have the most expensive health care in
the world compared to other
industrialized nations and the vast
majority of the money that we spend that
other countries don't spend it goes to a
couple of areas paperwork and profit
those those are the biggest areas of
waste in the American healthcare system
and so you could you could solve the
paperwork problem by having something
like a single-payer health care system
where we at least had some uniformity in
billing paperwork and collections you
know right now I remember visiting a
hospital in Bayonne New Jersey and which
I think subsequently shut down where
half of their administrative staff was
chasing collections and and because the
they were dealing with so many different
health insurance companies and they had
to do something so much work just to get
to the point where they were trying to
collect from the difference of different
health insurers that it its sapped all
their their bottom line and they
eventually went out of business I
believe and that system just makes no
sense to me and of course you know
profit in this this area I understand
the companies have to make money for
providing a service but when you know
half of the money that we spent on
health care is profit that doesn't make
sense to me either so um you know I'm
it's not an area of expertise for me but
clearly the American system is the most
irrational and illogical one in the
world and I agree with you I mean I
remember one of the things I enjoyed
about Russia is that when I got sick I
could just walk into a doctor's office
and you know the doctors there didn't
have the best equipment they didn't have
the best medicines always or their
shells or sometimes empty but they you
know they would see me and and you know
I think that that's something that this
generation is growing up without this
idea that healthcare is something that
you know you have a right to and I think
that's too bad so yeah in terms of Roger
Ailes incidentally you know I agree with
you I've had a lot of people say the
same things to me that they lost family
members over the years because
you know their fathers or mothers or
their odds or uncle's you know watch the
television all day long and became
increasingly angry and bitter and unable
to talk to their friends and relatives
anymore and I think the way we consume
media now and I think Fox is the pioneer
of this has made it impossible for
people with political differences to be
friends and that's that's really a shame
I mean when I grew up if I did I can't
remember it mattering what a person's
political opinions were and and now it
means everything and that's just a weird
thing I'm it's really strange isn't did
the Rolling Stones John winner assign
you the financial beat or did you ask to
cover that for many years um so I
believe what happened with yawn and so
after the the presidential election in
2008 because I'd covered that they
assigned me it was with yawn in my
editor at the time well Dana that we did
one story and they assigned one that was
about AIG if I remember correctly and
that was very difficult for me because I
had to understand I didn't know anything
so I'm starting from zero I had to learn
what a collateralized debt obligation
was or you know
CBS's and all these things and and so
that took me a long time but we did it
and we got such a huge response to it
because you know financial media up till
that point had exclusively been written
by people who were catering to people in
the finance sector there is no financial
reporting for ordinary people and so
this idea of translating for regular
people how Wall Street works it was a
new thing it had never been done before
and so we got such a response and we
just kept doing it and it turned into
eight years at work so it was that was a
really cool thing it was but but Yohn
know he was great during that entire
time I don't think that there are many
editors who would allow reporters to do
8,000 word features about
subprime mortgage fraud or you know how
foreclosure works these are really
arcane difficult labyrinthine topics and
they're not they don't sound sexy and
it's hard to sell advertising probably
to those those topics but he let me you
know explore them for a long long time
and it was really it was great great
stuff and you know I think that's all
you can ask for an editor is that they
support you in that way Matt Taibbi s
most recent book is insane clown
president we have another hour and a
half to go in our program today and
Chris and Montague Michigan you're on
the air
hi Matt I've been reading your articles
in flowing stone and I've seen some
similarities between your reporting and
Hunter s Thompson's and coverage of the
Nixon campaign I was just wondering if
he was an influence of yours
or who some of your other influences
might be thanks Lee span thanks that's
Chris Wright yeah yes Christian in
Michigan yeah yeah thanks for the
question yet clearly Hunter Thompson was
an influence of my I think every
political reporter in the country you
grew up reading his books actually one
of the high points of my entire career
was that I got to write the introduction
to the latest edition of fear and
loathing on the campaign trail that was
a huge honor for me I remember when I
was I think 15 years old my father and
another friend of mine we took a road
trip from from New York to Key West and
all we did the whole way down was was
read Hunter Thompson aloud in the car
and I love the way he wrote I thought he
was this weird four dimensional almost
kind of writer and it was so funny and
and he had his own language it wasn't
like dated he didn't write in 60s or 70s
language he kind of invented his own
strange language and I was really
fascinated by him he was an influence on
me and
I to copy him but it's really hard not
to you know especially since I have his
job and I'm covering the same stuff that
he was covering so it's hard not to fall
into those those patterns but in terms
of other reporters they you know I grew
up reading
HL Mencken also he was somebody who I
loved reading cherry southern and there
were a lot of Russians who I read over
the years who were I thought were great
writers sir Gates have lots of who was
kind of like a reporter he he wrote
wrote fiction but also they were sort of
journalism but yeah in terms of that I
mean there are other writers are who I
read who weren't journalists but of the
journalist I think those are the big
ones did you ever meet Hunter S times I
talked to him on the phone once a light
so I got assigned some publishing
company asked me to do a compilation
like a was supposed to be a book about
gonzo journalism so I was supposed to
put together a compilation of gonzo
reporting and I was young at the time
and I you know I kind of needed the
money and I started doing it and I chose
a whole bunch of articles and that I
thought kind of fit the tradition a
little bit but then I started to come up
against this problem that really when
you thought about it all gonzo
journalism it was like Hunter Thompson
you know and I thought I can't really do
this project without his assent and I
also you know I needed to know what he
thought about it so I called him up and
he said oh it sounds like a crappy
project and I said yeah and he goes how
badly do you need the money and I said
pretty badly and he goes well I can't be
part of it but good luck to you you know
and he basically guilted me out of doing
it so I didn't do it but he was cool you
know and I obviously since I've met lots
of people who knew him very well and and
he was nice to me you know
took my colleague Alexander sends in
this email I found insane clown
president at the library next to Neil
postman's among ourselves to death I'm
sorry amusing ourselves to death which I
was going to pick up reading them
together was quite interesting was
curious if you've ever read amusing
ourselves to death but if it was
influential to you okay well the second
part of that question is what are you
currently reading Matt and any
recommendations for the summer well one
of the things we do here on our in-depth
program is we ask our guests for what
they are reading some of the books that
have influenced them and some of their
other influences and here are the
responses that Matt Taibbi gave us
[Music]
[Music]
Matt Taibbi you list a couple of books
by evil and woz some of your favorite
scoop and decline and fall who was he
and why is he on your list he was a very
funny
British writer satirist I think his
books they have almost like a candied
like quality to them they're really they
rush from scene to scene they're like a
lot of British writers they're of that
genre
he has incredibly witty dialogue you
know it's sort of in the Oscar Wilde no
coward kind of vain but what I or Graham
Greene was another one of my favorite
writers but what I love about even was
that his books are just so beautifully
structured they're still incredibly
economical he you know every line is is
tight there's no wasted motion any of it
and it's just they're hilarious and
start to finish and make you think scoop
which is a book that every foreign
correspondent carries on his or her
person you know all over the world it's
a great story about am a guy who has a
gardening column in in a British
newspaper and he by accident gets
dispatched to cover a civil war in the
in Abyssinia in the middle of Africa and
you could it's it's like all comedies
the misunderstanding basically an
influential person asks for somebody by
that name and the editor mistakenly
thinks is this gardening columnist and
so they send them out to this brutal
place and um and it's just hilariously
funny and and why he is he's like a
great model for for just satire in
general because he has this kind of
panoramic view of the entire absurdity
of the human experience and you know on
top of that just in terms of his
craftsmanship he was just an incredibly
incredibly polished seamless kind of
writer so he kind of checks all the
boxes for me
have you read Anna Karenina Oh in
Russian in Russian yeah that was one of
the first books was actually read in
Russian and I know how that sounds
because it's such a big book but Tolstoy
one of the great things about Tolstoy I
can't believe I just said that that
sounds what pretentious but but what
Tolstoy is writing you know even in
English even in translation it comes
through that he has this an incredible
rare gift for the powerful simple
sentence right like he he finds the
absolute simplest way to communicate the
most complicated thoughts and the his
his prose has this kind of like
pulsating
force you know that kind of picks up
speed over time and you even in even in
Russian he he you know my Russian is
good but not fantastic let's put that
way but you know uses simple words and
simple structure in a way that is is
just I think gorgeous and it's
interesting because I also like some
writers some Russian writers who have
the absolutely opposite quality like
Gogol and Dostoevsky they you know they
both dusty ask it was a big fan of
Gogol's Gogol was a fan of these huge
sprawling sentences and paragraphs that
are just crammed through with
subordinate clauses and it's like really
difficult to follow and baroque and but
that but I like that style too it's just
there are two different ways of
achieving the same thing but what's also
is you know just the simplicity is
amazing and beautiful and ingenious and
now you're a fan of footnotes using
footnotes in your work footnotes yeah
yeah and again again I grew up I was way
more
fan of the kind of Gogol method growing
up which is that is to have huge long
run-on sentences and complications and
subordinate clauses and parenthesis and
and I thought it was a cool thing to
kind of force the reader to do a little
bit of work you know on the way to
getting to the point or to the punch
line or whatever it was and you know
footnotes and and you know taking
various journeys on the way to finishing
that was used to do that much more now
now I'm trying to go the other way and
make more simple declarative sentences
and you know use fewer adverbs and
subordinate clauses and stuff like that
on your current reading list can't we
disagree more constructively by Jonathan
hate yeah look about this Jonathan Haidt
he's a I believe a professor here in New
York City and this is just because I've
been really really depressed by the
state of American politics lately and
I'm I just think the partisan nature of
it has become so angry and so like
unredeemed you know it and it's not it's
the opposite of uplifting you know like
when when I read a political book I
usually want to feel better about life
so or at least clearer you know and now
most of the time when I'm reading
political writing it's just a bunch of
people denouncing another bunch of
people and because I've become
interested in the idea of the story is
there another way is there anything
that's happier out there you know and
it's that was why I read before this
book I read a book called utopia for
realists by a Dutch writer named Rutger
I record Bregman I think it's his name
and it's just all about you know another
approach to politics that's vastly
different and can't biking we have big
ideas anymore and and so you know I'm
reading John Payne's doesn't necessarily
mean that I agree with him I'm just
looking around for somebody who's we've
got a different approach to politics and
that that isn't just
you know blue versus red I just so tired
of that narrative Matt Taibbi is our
guest on book TV here is how you can
contact us this afternoon
202 is area code seven four eight 8200
if you live in the east and central time
zone seven four eight eight two zero one
for those of you in the mountain and
Pacific time zones now throughout the
show we'll also put up our social media
addresses if you can't get through on
the phone line and still want to get a
comment or a question in Matt Taibbi is
the author of seven books his first one
came out in 2000 and this is called the
Exile sex drugs and libel in the new
Russia spanking the donkey came out in
2005 dispatches from the dumb season
smells like dead elephants dispatches
from rotting empire in 2007 sorry
spanking the donkey came out no five the
great derangement a terrifying true
story of war politics and religion 2009
Griff topia story of bankers politicians
and the most audacious power grab in
American history came out in 2011 and
the divided American injustice in the
age of the wealth gap 2014 and insane
clown president dispatches from the 2016
circus just came out this year and what
I asked you about something you wrote in
the great derangement and of course I've
lost that piece of paper right now so
we'll have to I see it right down here
but if you could explain what this is
about
oh I have a confession to make
it's not something that's easy to
explain but here goes after two days of
nearly constant religious instruction
songs worship and praise two days that
for me meant an unending regime of
forced and fake responses a funny thing
started to happen to my head so this was
I was undercover right this was a I was
trying to do I guess it was a little bit
of a spin on like you know the kind of
like a black like me kind of a thing you
know instead of a sort of immerse myself
in this apocalyptic Church down in Texas
and it was one of those mega churches
where they believed the end of the world
is coming and you know their rapturous
basically was what they're called the
pastor's sort of a famous guy named John
Hagee he's a big supporter of John
McCain and I was just interested in what
that mindset was like and so in order to
do that I had to craft this persona and
join the church and I came up with this
alternative identity and I went away on
retreats and learned all the prayers and
and did all this stuff and and I think
that's the section of the book where I'm
talking about how I started to like it
after a while and you know that was kind
of a key insight for me which was that
it's there was a soothing quality to all
these rituals and you know the first
time I walked into the church and it
wasn't the music oh this is the worst
music I've ever heard in my life but
then after after about five weeks of
this you know I started to sing along
with it I was getting into it and by the
time I left it was getting to the poor
right I thought I have to get out of
here before you know something happens
to me permanently so you know that was
it was an interesting moment I was
trying to I was trying to explain how
how people can fall for something then
on the outside seems ridiculous but you
know they they took people who are
vulnerable who are going through
difficult things in their lives and they
gave them answers and some of them were
simplistic but it provided comfort and I
was just trying to understand that let's
hear from Marie in La Mesa California hi
Marie hi thank you so much for having
book TV I've been a longtime follower
and also a longtime follower Matt Taibbi
regarding that the last thing that he
addressed about
enjoying the the church that he was
going to a social psychologist speak to
that and of course marketers know very
well how the brain works I'm 80 years
old I'm a volunteer with a knsj and San
Diego community radio independent
non-commercial station and I was
wondering if Matt has suggestions about
community radio across the United States
we provide an alternative voice in San
Diego to what we're hearing on the news
constantly here and met you you said
that we should be seen as the truth in
reporting news and I'm wondering I'm
wondering how as you go on your speaking
tours and you're talking about the Trump
administration Trump himself when we see
a personal view of someone who reports
news then for those who read what that
news person writes do we do we see can
we see the truth I mean that's a good
question you know the question of how do
you get at the truth what would like for
instance it's Marie right I've read so
the on you know for community radio just
to answer that part of the question
first I've never worked in radio before
but I do think that that local media
is making a little bit of a comeback and
some of it is through internet-based
media like podcasts which have taken
ideas like serial and they've done it
for their own and I think that's one
thing that's great that community radio
can do easily and with relatively low
costs as do things like you know 12 part
series about local issues right so you
can do you know some local scandal or a
crime or a trial and it'll be
interesting to your listeners because
they it's in their neighborhood and it's
about people they know but you you can
use storytelling techniques you know you
don't have you can make characters out
of people I think that's one of the cool
things about the kind of flowering of
new media is as much as I've been
critical of the fracturing of it we have
all these new innovations in form now
that make it really make we've found all
these different new interesting ways to
tell stories and to do the news so if I
were in community radio now I'd be
really excited about all different
things that I could do you know you
could essentially make a kind of rolling
reality show about about a local trial
or I don't know even a local little
league team or anything you know and
these these are things that we wouldn't
have thought to do 40 or 50 years ago
when news is always you know on the
radio it's four minute broadcast of this
or that or at this hawkship talk show
now you can do you know sophisticated
storytelling you can do undercover
things all kinds of cool stuff you can
do it radio so you know I would just try
to be as creative as possible with that
and and and take advantage of the fact
the ER local and that's the way to
compete with national with national
media you know you you know the
characters better than NBC CBS CNN know
them so that's that's an advantage that
you have
in terms of trying to be truthful and
can we ever really know the truth I mean
I I that's a huge you metaphysical
question but what I would say is you
know the best way to kind of arrive at
an understanding of what's going on in
the world for me is just to consume as
many different sources as possible and
and try to get at what the common themes
are you know like for instance one when
I was trying to learn about Wall Street
and I didn't know anything going into it
what I would do is I would call 20 or 30
people and ask them the same question
you know what is a collateralized debt
obligation how does it work or oh you
know what's this what's a synthetic CDO
and and or what happened in with the
Lehman bankruptcy and you know I would
get 30 stories and 25 of them would be
similar and you know then you start to
take the common threads and that's it's
always an amalgamating process when
you're trying to figure out what's
actually going on you're never going to
get the whole unvarnished truth from
anybody but you know that's what we do
as human beings we got to put it all
together but that's what being informed
is all about just read as much as
possible
have you gotten into podcasts I mean
either listening or creating I listen to
them and I may be starting a podcast
soon so you know it's not quite ready to
look to go but yeah I'm thinking about
doing that so I think it's a cool it's a
cool thing it's the it's a neat way of
kind of communicating with your audience
and and it also allows you to do some
different stuff I mean you know the one
of the work that I do it's pretty tough
to do you know comedy or anything that's
or movie reviews or book reviews it
allows you to kind of go at different
directions and I think it's neat I think
there's a lot of really interesting work
going on with that next call Eric is in
Middletown New York Eric you're on book
TV with Matt Taibbi hi good afternoon
gentlemen nice to talk tables now I've
got a bit of a complex one here for you
um
and I can touch on just about every
single thing that's been been part of
the discussion this morning uh first off
your dad was my news guy along with
Johnny and to Simmons for about the
first 25 years of my life but under
network yeah yeah it's you know I grew
up on that stuff and I spent many years
in Manhattan and Brooklyn as a funeral
director I think I spotted you a couple
of times around the NYU campus
background all specific seven eight so
um anyone I'm wondering yeah I mean you
got girl look to you um you know and
you're definitely your father's son you
guys a couple handsome fellas so in any
event I'm wondering you know it's funny
this last caller from public or you know
not profit non-commercial radio on like
ow huh eight years old still kicking
tail but any any event you mentioned you
guys are discussing the utility of a
thing like a trial and that's something
I'm dealing with and it involves a
corporate line something you touchdown
with the California welfare case well
they'll go after individual benefit
recipients but not these larger
companies that are just reading these
massive quantities and money I'm
wondering are you familiar with a case
of New York that basically on its tenth
year it's been through the entire
appellate structure has created new law
and it's entitled Landon's the Kroll it
involves criminal justice system drug
testing are you familiar with it at all
all right Eric thank you very much Matt
Taibbi I know I I'm not familiar with it
but I'm interested in it could we go on
I'm curious what he is not with us
anymore so you're going to have to do
your own research on that case I
apologize
but you do talk and I want to say it's
from Griff topia you talk about the fact
that it's much easier to get a slam-dunk
conviction but not to take a case a
complex case to court that could last 10
20 years yeah no I I heard this over and
over again from prosecutors they said
look look at it from our point of view
right like we get evaluated according to
how many convictions we did so
if you're us are you going to go take
HSBC to court and they have the best
lawyers in the world and the standard of
proof is it's not easy to meet you know
or are we going to take 50 drug dealers
to court and get wins on all of them and
some of them you know we just throw them
in the box and we we scare them and they
confess you know whereas with these
gigantic financial institutions it won't
admit a thing they dig in they've got
the best lawyers in the world and even
when they're plainly guilty it is
extremely difficult to get convictions I
mean I covered a trial or it takes it
takes so long that you know they
sometimes can wait out the the criminal
justice system and then force them into
mistakes because they are trying to get
within the statute of limitations I I
covered a case that involved bid rigging
in the municipal bond market and they
had these guys on tape and it was they
clearly clearly had them but it took so
long to get that case the court among
other things that they had to educate
the jury about all the jargon and they
had to defeat so many motions just to
get there that by the time they you know
they went to trial they ended up losing
some of the defendants because they
didn't meet the 10-year statute of
limitations you know so if you're a
prosecutor
it is a difficult choice here you're
going to take on these banks and you're
going to lose a lot of the time and and
but the problem is I still think
symbolically you got to try because
otherwise what you're saying to the
people is you know we're giving up right
we're just going to take the money from
these guys because it's too hard to take
them to trial so we'll take the check
and then we're going to put these people
in jail which invalidates jail as far as
I'm concerned you know that that makes
it makes it if you know if a certain
class of people can't go to jail and a
certain only a certain class of people
can then that's not legitimate criminal
justice to me so you know I think you
have to try anyway next call is Rob and
Milford Connecticut Rob please go ahead
the only conservative was called in
today I'm quite sure Peter I hope I can
get my comment in question out because
as we conservative see nationwide the
left is a very intolerant of
disagreeable voices you talked earlier
about not liking the words liberal and
conservative their shorthand but you
went to Bard College which is an
extremely liberal College you work for
me and yon winner who's an extremely
liberal man you've quoted HL Mencken 100
Thompson hundreds picture on the screen
you've integrated Roger Ailes Fox News
you use the word conservative twice you
haven't used the word liberal I
understand what you said in I agree
there's no such thing as objectivity but
my comment is I think that you are as
partisan as Fox News just on the other
side
my question is to do with race over the
past 50 years by every single metric all
negative human behavior is
disproportionately occupied by black and
Latino people I contend that black and
Latino men roughly between the ages of
15 and 40 15 and 45 has been in our
today our greatest domestic liability a
trillion dollars have been spent since
1965 the war on poverty map please
answer this question I can't get one
liberal anywhere here at Yale to answer
this is there any country in sub-saharan
Africa or where Spanish is spoken whose
standard of living is comparable or
greater than ours
Matt ie that was robbed in Milford
Connecticut I don't even know where to
begin with with that question it's
preposterous if you what you're really
saying is that you think that they that
inherently racially black and Hispanic
people are more prone to negative
behavior than white people I mean is
that that that's what you're saying
it with that question it's it's absurd
it's it's preposterous and I think you
should be ashamed of yourself yeah if
you want if you want to come after me
and say I'm a liberal and I'm an upper
upper middle class white cated went to
Bard College and I work for Yan winter
and you know you don't see any
difference between me and FoxNews that's
fine even though I clearly regularly go
after the Democratic Party in my it
might work and I've
never heard once foxnews take on a
conservative on that on that station you
know I try to look at everybody and I
disagree with people you know of my own
political character all the time because
I think that's healthy it's not a
business for me I don't do this for to
try to scare liberals into tuning into
my articles that I can make money this
is about trying to call things as I see
them and that's not what that's not what
Fox News does and I think that your your
your views I couldn't disagree with them
more strongly and I feel sorry for you
that you feel that way this is Carolyn
in Spearfish South Dakota Matt how much
blame should below this is an email how
much blame should belong to the New York
Times and Washington Post for so
excoriating Trump that the voters went
the other way in response I don't know
about singling out those two
publications but I do think that that
was a phenomenon that was true when we
you know I talked about this in my book
that when when the reporters went after
Trump he rose in the polls he didn't go
down every single time he had one of
those scandals like for instance after
you know I when he said I like people
who aren't captured about John McCain
you know the conventional wisdom among
the press corps was that's what
unsurvivable scandal right you know you
can maybe say things bad things about
Mexicans in America would but veterans
come on I mean that no politician has
ever survived something like that and
not only did he not go down in the polls
when he was excoriated in the media he
heroes and then when he was confronted
about it he denied that he ever said it
and the media went after him or anyone
went up higher in the polls and I think
what we learned in that experience we
should have learned is that you know the
huge section of the public dislikes us
more than they dislike Donald Trump or
and they distrust us more than they
distrust somebody like Donald Trump and
this is why I have
a little bit of trouble with people who
say things like the media didn't callout
Trump enough because we we certainly did
it was just that we don't have any
influence over a segment of the
population anymore and that's you know I
think we have to examine why that is
what why are we not listened to by
people out there and I think some of it
the class thing some of it's just that
we are not interested in the same things
that Trump voters are interested in but
whatever it is we have to we have to
address because that was a problem from
the 2009 book the great derangement Matt
Taibbi writes Washington politicians
basically viewed the people as a
capricious and dangerous enemy a dumb
mob whose only interesting quality
happens to be in their power to take
away politicians jobs right yeah I mean
this is something I hear over and over
again from people who work in Congress
and heard a lot of stories from people
who tell talk about how the worst job in
a Senate office or a House office is the
person who has to answer the constituent
telephone calls you know I hear stories
about people who sit there and when the
phone rings they just hold up hold it
like this they you know politicians look
at the voter is a kind of haranguing
nuisance who yeah I'm [ __ ] generally
there are obviously exceptions that I've
got I've run into but for the most part
politics can be conducted without a
whole lot of interaction with the voter
basically you you construct a policy
that is that your donors support you get
money from your donors in exchange for
creating legislation that they like than
you do commercials
you put the commercials on air you do
you do appearances in the legacy media
and you run elections that way when most
of them are on a boat you know not
seriously opposed anyway so you know if
if you play your cards right you
basically don't have to leave Washington
in order to get reelected I mean you can
go you have to go home symbolically to
make a few appearances but is the way
the game is played now it's all about
raising money and doing commercials and
doing legacy
appearances and you can do all of that
without really talking to people and I
think that's that's a big problem with
our politics and interestingly sorry to
interrupt Trump differ from that Trump
based his entire strategy on talking to
people on the physically interacting
with people in all these small towns and
it was hugely successful this is Joe
this is an email New York City Trump
wants to repeal mccarran-ferguson Act of
1944 allow insurance companies to cross
state lines
you wrote that in Grif topia it is yeah
I was really I was really interested to
hear I remember hearing him talk about
that before the fruit for the first time
in New Hampshire he said it in a very
strange way you kind of talked about
insurance companies and how they in the
lines it didn't quite make sense of
first but then I realized he was talking
about the antitrust exemption but I
haven't seen any evidence that he he
wants to repeal the antitrust exemption
enjoyed by health insurance companies so
it could turn out to be one of these
things that you know Trump talks about a
lot of things that he wanted to do on
the campaign trail but we're not seeing
in any evidence that he's actually going
to do them like you know he wanted to
end the the the carried interest tax
break you know for people and who are in
private equity well you know where is
that proposal now you know that so we'll
see
I was interesting hearing and talk about
it he and it was one of many kind of
populist themes that he sounded as a
candidate but that seemed to work with
people and but you know again as
president what is he going to carry
through in any of it you know we'll see
I don't know I don't know I wrote about
this the other day I mean he he a
similar example was you know he was in
favor of drug and importing drugs from
Canada but we haven't seen any evidence
that he's really pushing for that either
so you know he's saying that Barack
Obama came in rock Obama exactly so this
is this is again it's a problem with
American
politics which is that campaigns don't
have a whole lot of connection to
reality they're just shows and people
tend to be much more progressive or
populist in there as candidates and they
are once they get elected what would be
the upside or the downside in your view
mr. Kay idea of changing
mccarran-ferguson well it would increase
in competition between your insurance
companies right now they don't have to
compete with each other and you because
of these the antitrust exemptions they
enjoy they basically have little fiefdom
and each state in each state yeah
exactly and you know it was something
that they got early on you know I guess
it was in the early 50s that they got
this exemption and they've had it ever
since and it's one of the main reasons
why health insurance prices are so high
and the cost of health care is so high
and I think you know I also favor you
know other other approaches to the
health care problem that would be more
you know less market-based maybe but but
if we're going to go a market-based
solution that we have to at least you
know make it more like a free-market you
know right now it's essentially of a big
protectionist racket where you know the
country's divvied up into little
territories and they get to charge
whatever they want within those
territories from insane clown president
Matt Taibbi z-- most recent book voters
in America not only aren't over
empowered they for decades now have been
almost totally disenfranchised subjects
of one of the more brilliant chains
suppressing change suppressing systems
ever invented I'm going to read that one
more time because I stumbled way too
much voters in America not only aren't
over empowered they for decades now been
almost totally disenfranchised subjects
of one of the more brilliant chains
suppressing systems ever invented yeah
and I said well all I was saying is that
the it's all the things that we talked
about here today voters they only
they've only had two choices for the
most part and both of those choices have
tended to be supported by the same
gigantic corporate donors so there's a
weeding out process that has been
happening before people even get to the
point where they actually get to make a
political choice we essentially
eliminate everybody who doesn't have the
assent of the national news media of the
political donor class and of the two
major political parties that that has
been a triumvirate that is kind of
closely guarded the gates of power for
decades in this country and you know yes
we get to choose between one of two
parties that are acceptable to those
groups but that's not a terribly wide
amount of political choice interestingly
Trump kind of broke that mold you know
he he was a true outsider you know in a
way he didn't need the money of the
donor class to get elected and he didn't
even didn't use the media to get elected
in a traditional way and he was an
outsider to the Republican Party so he
didn't use their political machinery so
there is a blueprint now for somebody
else to get elected unfortunately when
we finally had a real political choice
you know we I think spent it on the
wrong person but you know it was
interesting next call from Seb comes
from Linda in Phoenix Linda please go
ahead we're listening
yes great program as always and I loved
her talking about the great Russian
writers that reread in New York in the
public schools in high school in the
public schools but my my question or
comment is during the course of this
whole program we the the essence has
been a very bleak picture here in the
United States the polarization I go back
my generation is at the end more
generation and even
in the 60s we weren't as polarized
economically politically culturally as
we are today it is so disturbing for
people for persons of my generation
right now we can't see this continuing
on as it is how can we continue on as a
sovereign nation with the government
that is inoperable that that is growing
lis inoperable and all we I can see is
given history the divisions the strong
divisions and an electorate where one in
six persons believes that democracy is
not important to them how can this not
eventually erupt in civil unrest to the
to to suppress the causes spell I it
being any we've it there and let's hear
from Matt Taibbi yeah thanks Linda I
totally agree with you I'm distressed
about all the same things I I think
we're in an age of polarization that is
we're going in a direction that's
unsustainable I remember way back when I
was writing The Grates arrangement
actually even before that I did this I
did a story where I was like undercover
working and the Bush campaign in 2004
and I remember listening to people this
was back then just about Republicans but
the thing that was really interesting to
me is that they didn't have a vision of
the country that included the you know
sort of liberals they all they really
wanted their idea this sort of fantasy
conception of the perfect America was a
world word just these these liberal
professors and actors from Hollywood and
media figures they just didn't exist
anymore they didn't want if they didn't
want to get along with them they just
wanted them kind of out of the way and I
thought wow that's such a negative istic
vision of the country like we have to
have
a vision where everybody kind of finds a
way to get along and they don't have
that now I see the same thing going on
with the other side I see you know
there's a new kind of politics that I
think has come up in the last year or so
where it's not if you're a Democrat
sometimes it's not about here's what we
stand for positively what we're the
biggest thing that they're about is
being against Republicans and they don't
have a vision of the country that
includes you know Republicans and look I
understand there are frustrations people
are angry they believe that the
Republicans made a racist choice they're
misogynist and and but you know we have
to live together ultimately all of us
and so there has to be somebody has to
come up with a way that allows us all to
talk to each other again and I don't
know what that is but I think that's
that's the magic formula going forward
is is we have to have some kind of
national reconciliation and I hope it's
sooner rather than later
from insane clown president Matt Taibbi
writes at politics used to be a simple
predictable con every four years the
money men in DC would team up with party
hacks to throw their weight behind
whatever half-bright fraud of a
candidate proved most adept at snowing
the population into buying a warmed-over
version of the same crappy policies
they've always thought did 2016 change
on that yeah definitely I think it did
in the future to possibly I mean what
what happened with Trump and to a lesser
extent Sanders upset the applecart name
maybe forever because the formula has
changed now again in the old days in
order to win in order to in order to
actually get to the White House as
opposed to just being interesting and a
factor like Ross Perot in order to
actually win you needed that
institutional support of the party of
the money and the press now you know
what what Trump and and Sanders both
showed is that the voting public is
a way of thinking for itself now that
doesn't include this sort of
institutional you know bureaucratic
structure and so it's not as simple a
matter of as a bunch of people with
money getting together we're the party
elder isn't deciding who's going to be
the salesman who's going to who's going
to sell the pol of the policies to the
people now we you know it's it's a bit
of an open season you know there anybody
anybody can run anybody can win and you
know in Trump in the case of Trump that
turned out to be a negative but it's
interesting at least you know it's
opened up the the possible range of
possibilities how long did it take you
to write a paragraph like that that we
just rest
oh I don't know I you know I I write
fairly quickly I guess um but I obsess I
think that writers do it different ways
you know I heard I register lacrosse
once that he something about the way he
writes that he writes like 500 words a
day or something like this and I may be
missing who this was about but the whole
point was to you know that they would
think get the sentence correct ahead of
time and then and then committed to
paper and handwritten I I put text down
pretty quickly but then I sort of
obsessively go back and and play with it
until it's smaller and and tighter and
so it's everybody does it a different
way campaigns needed people only as
props Matt Taibbi writes if a candidate
wanted to show that he or she was with
it on racial issues that candidate would
visit a predominantly black high school
and be photographed clapping to a school
band performance if he wanted a
worker-friendly image he'd visit a
robotics Factory in Wisconsin and be
photographed wearing a hard hat and
goggles and so on right yeah and again
this is just the same thing that what I
was talking about before you don't
really need people to be a politician
anymore you need them to be props for
photo ops but to actually talk to them
have their support
you know that they had they had mastered
a way of running elections that did not
necessarily involve the active and you
know they active participation of voters
and they were able to do it through you
know money stage craft production values
all that stuff allowed them to bypass
you know the old school version of
politics where you had to actually go
into the union halls and and end or you
know Elks Club or whatever it was and
convince people now it's not done that
way anymore you know I think and Trump
incidentally this pioneering an even
more interesting way of running politics
which is he didn't even have a campaign
he just was literally a human being with
a couple of overheated ganglia behind
his eyes appearing on television and he
just let the entire media system be his
campaign structure and you know he
didn't even he didn't even need staff
let alone people provided to run his
campaign so that was interesting too and
sometimes his speeches would just be all
risks wasn't it they were almost all
entirely risks you know I talked to my
first boss and journalism was the late
wing Barrett who is a investigative
reporter here in at the Village Voice he
died earlier this year but he was one of
Trump's first biographers and I talked
to Wayne about Trump and one of the
things he told me was that Donald Trump
had never in his life read a prepared
text until his father died and he read
something at his funeral and so I
watched out for that you know and what
you would see on the campaign trail with
Trump was you would go to a place and
sometimes his campaign would distribute
a flyer that would have the prepared
remarks on it and the first line would
say something like well so great to be
back in Manchester and he would say it's
so great to be back in Manchester and
then the second line on was always all
like ad lib he couldn't he's like
constitutionally incapable of sticking
to a script although he did do it for a
brief period after after Steve Anand got
which I thought was interesting and that
that period kind of changed his campaign
when he did this bizarre thing about
about reaching out to the
african-american voter and he actually
read those speeches you know you could
see it was almost he was almost like a
prisoner war reading you know but um but
for the most part he just gets up there
and riffs and yeah I think he even he
doesn't know what he's going to say most
of the time next call for Matt Taibbi
comes from Elizabeth and San Marcos
California Elizabeth please go ahead
we're listening
hi I love your work Matt but I called in
to mention that Obama never really gets
credit for landing the plane after the
economy was headed off the cliff and you
know then the Ben the plane landed on
the oceans and everybody got into the
lifeboats and the Republicans refused to
row you know so with that as a backdrop
I think it really affected Obama's
ability in his early days to get a lot
of things accomplished like single-payer
given that our health care system is
like one-fifth of the economy at that
time you know all these jobs you to
eliminate those at that point would have
been kept as you know catastrophic
better anyway I want to jump in on your
media thing and ask your question I
don't think that Trump you know number
one we have a now a shattered media
environment you know Trump sends out
tweaks and everybody is shaken around
like a laser pointer and and big issues
are not getting address you know
everyone's running off to talk about
some saying you know Cochiti or whatever
and the underlying issues that democracy
really demands a lot of it's boring you
know it's you know try to get a hundred
people in a room to agree on anything
and that's kind of what our system is
built on and but would you agree that in
our media environment today trend really
didn't do it alone
I mean Drivetime radio is all
conservative other than NPR and Fox News
is they're showing an alternate universe
from what you're seeing on CNN and so
the idea that CNN and MSNBC created
Trump I don't necessarily buy that you
know given the number of men that are
driving around they have jobs as drivers
in this this country today
you know that's who's driving around in
the middle of the country they're
listening to Rush Limbaugh more Ingraham
and you know so many conservative
talkers and there are no very very few
liberal talkers
so anyway could you comment on that a
little bit thank you that's Elizabeth
and San Marcos yeah Elizabeth um Texas
it's just to quickly talk about the
first thing because I that's a little
bit sort of near and dear to my heart
the whole issue of Barack Obama and his
response to the financial crisis I
remember talking to people on Wall
Street before Obama took office is
during the transition in 2008 when the
you know the economy was in full
meltdown mode and clearly they were they
were still in the process of
constructing the bailouts and the
bailiffs were incidentally almost a
completely bipartisan effort they what
Obama and Tim Geithner did were
essentially the same things that that
george w bush and hank paulson started
what wall the economy began to tank in
september but beyond that I remember
talking to lots of people on Wall Street
and you know not everybody had this year
but some people had this view that they
were looking forward to Barack Obama
coming into office because he was
somebody who had incredible
communication skills and would be able
to get up in front of the country and
explain what had happened with the
subprime mortgage crisis which was this
incredibly involved complicated fraud
that had essentially been perpetrated on
the markets on
and had disproportionately targeted you
know sort of people of color and lower
income individuals and had led to this
massive foreclosure crisis and Obama
really didn't do that he elected to sort
of not address the root cause of the
crisis in his response to it and he did
he continued a policy that the
Republicans started which was to
essentially throw a huge sum of money at
the financial services sector to allow
him to get well again and they did and
and it worked to a degree but there were
sort of persistent structural problems
that were left in place that laid the
groundwork for I think future problems
in the markets so yeah you know I
understand that he inherited and I'm
from unimpressive in problem but at
least in the area of the stuff that I
covered you know I think he was he was
disappointing at least on my on that
level because he was he was somebody who
could have sorted out which was a
something that was a very difficult
topic for the for the public and he
really just declined to do it you know
when he did get a chance to talk about
on 60 minutes one of the few things that
he said was some of the worst some of
the least ethical behavior on Wall
Street wasn't illegal okay which is
really lowering I mean it's true that
doesn't mean that other bad behavior on
Wall Street wasn't illegal it just means
that some of it wasn't illegal in he I
think he he was trying to split the baby
in a way with that issue and and you
know that was that was disappointing to
me on the other issue about you know
Trump not doing it alone well the only
thing I would say to that is those you
know dry afternoon radio and Fox and The
Daily Caller and all those things I've
always been there and and Barack Obama
overcame them and he won an election by
10 million votes and in 2008 I don't
think those those that the media
landscape is not
an insuperable obstacle to a skilled
politician I think what happened with
the Trump phenomenon was there was a
perfect storm of a disaffected public a
candidate who was uniquely suited to
take advantage of the kind of reality
show format of the campaign coverage and
then there was a democratic you know
candidate that was kind of in disarray
and fed into a lot of the rhetoric that
Trump was was laying out there so yeah I
mean he had he had all that yet it's
back up so of other politicians and they
failed back to insane clown president
Trump supporters are people who are
tired of being told that they have to be
part of some kind of coalition in order
to have a political voice they
particularly hate being lectured about
alienating minorities especially by
members of their own party yeah and this
was a this is something oddly enough
that David Fromm talked about in a in an
article for the Atlantic you know after
Mitt Romney lost in 2012 the Republicans
kind of looked at what the results and
said you know geez if we just did a
little bit better with Hispanics we'd
probably have won that election and so
they started casting about for a
candidate who would have liked a softer
message on immigration and that time
that was why Jeb Bush ended up with a
hundred million dollars in his you know
his campaign effort early on in that
race but it turned out that the
Republican electorate was in a
completely different place that that's
not where they wanted to go they didn't
want to be a more inclusive party they
didn't want to be more open-minded they
didn't want to welcome more people into
the tent they wanted what what Donald
Trump was selling which was something
you know very different in fact he
wanted to close the borders and send
everybody back and so I think the party
was was out of touch with its own
electorate
and you know they were probably right in
terms of where the party should have
gone but you know it's a different
matter to convince people to go there
this is book TV on c-span - Matt
baby is our in-depth author guest this
month and math is calling in from Great
Barrington Massachusetts I'm Ike how you
doing hello are you doing yeah
it's Matt Taibbi if I said Mike I
apologize that's his father go ahead
Matt problem it's gotta come out I
really appreciate the way you can slog
through really complicated stuff like
financial world and come out and explain
it and make it clear there's another
area that's very complicated that no one
touches on about why we have an insane
clown president why there are so many
insane things is biology there was a dr.
hammer in early 80s that proved that the
cause of all disease and mental disease
is caused by shocks to the system this
is all empirically proven he's like
Snowden living in Norway they won't even
let him out at all and I was wondering
you seem like a person that could
actually slog through Russian and
financial [ __ ] and really get to the
bottom of it but no one brings up
biology that were animals doing all this
[ __ ] here alright we're going to leave
it there Matt in Great Barrington
Massachusetts and Matt Taibbi here in
New York any any response for that I I
don't know that the doctors work so I
don't think I could comment on it and
you know I'm not against doing medical
stories but that sounds like a big one
to try to tackle so I don't know you
don't need to comment if you don't want
to this is an email from Marcellus are
from yet from Marcellus two things
why is sake h/h monroe one of your
favorite writers and why did you leave
intercept online website well on to the
second question first was deleted less
pleasant one so I was going to start up
a publication called a website called
racket which was going to be part of the
first look media and
Iyer and you know all I can say is that
it didn't work out I had disagreements
with management and unfortunately that
that project never got off the ground it
was too bad we had a lot of really
talented cool people there and we were
trying to recreate and if you remember
spy magazine that we wanted to do
something kind of like that and and it
just didn't work out unfortunately that
a money issue no no it was it was it was
complicated it was sort of an
interpersonal thing I would say you know
do clash of philosophies and you know I
I just didn't and I may not be the best
boss in the world either so you know I
think that that that I didn't work out
but it's stupid it's too bad but it were
really good people for the most part in
terms of socky shocky is another he is
actually not very well known to American
audiences writer named Hector Hugh Munro
he's a little bit like wah in a way
they're a little bit similar in style of
it sake was had a much darker blacker
sense of humor if I remember correctly
his mother was trampled to death by a
cow so he he hit he wrote a lot of short
stories that were sort of famous for
having a very ambitious you know there
was often a terrible animal in the story
and people were getting torn apart by
polecats and things like that but he had
a very nasty dark view of the sort of
upper crust
British aristocrats in those two the
last phase of the British Empire and he
was a brilliant wordsmith very screwed
up person personally but he he he wrote
these gorgeous incredibly funny stories
that were really some of my favorites
growing up I actually named my second
son his middle name is Monroe laughter
after sake and and I strongly advise
anybody who's never read sake stories to
go do
because they're they're really short you
can read them you know in half an hour
but they're they're just really int and
so funny and it's too bad that he's not
a veteran in the space have you had any
interaction at this point with the Trump
White House have you called the press
off I have yeah you know I've I've
talked to some people in the Trump White
House not on the record though so you
know I I think one of the things that
happened when this rush of story started
to break is I I just for my own
curiosity I tried to figure out a lot of
things so I've been calling a lot of
people and in Congress and Senate in the
White House to trying to make sense of
it but I haven't gotten enough to be
able to report on so unfortunately I
don't have anything that I can really
contribute Don
well Eric Levinson tweets in on Russia
there are two stories that Matt
conflates did Russia interfere in the
election did Trump collude with Russia
no that's actually what I don't conflate
I've said from the beginning that and if
you look back you'll see this and the
first stories that I wrote about this
that I wouldn't be surprised at all if
Russia was responsible for the hack of
the DNC you know later when Donald Trump
himself said I think it was probably
Russia I wrote about that too I mean I I
don't I don't actually conflate those
things I think I think the problem is
that people do conflate them you know my
issue with this story is okay let's say
that that's true right
that doesn't necessarily follow that
Trump and the Russians concluded on to
do this you know if you think about it
from a logical point of view there's no
upside for the Russians to even involve
Trump in that caper if they if they
wanted to I mean it that's that's the
problem that I have is that is people
think that when I'm saying I don't see
proof of the collusion that I'm saying
that nothing happened I'm not saying
that I'm saying I'm saying if you want
to call someone a traitor who's
espionage against the United States you
need something a little bit more solid
than I think so you know it's just not
you know that that's that's where I am
with that James in Denham Springs
Louisiana dear sir whenever I read your
Rolling Stone articles about politicians
and their misconduct I get so mad that I
have to put down the magazine and get a
drink or take a walk around the block do
you get just as mad while you're writing
about them and their shenanigans yeah I
mean some sometimes but you know the
writing about it is kind of the way I
exercise that a little bit again part of
the job is to get upset so you know you
try to find ways to make sure that
you're responding correctly to something
that's horrible you know I think it if
you're not getting upset you debt that's
when you know that something's going on
and you're probably been doing it for
too long
fill Portland Oregon a few minutes left
with our guest Matt Taibbi well thank
you c-span hello Matt just a quick call
now for my question I click on it before
my question and that this political
system is quite sustainable as long as
profit from office political office
continues the 90% answer to this profit
from the office term limits now my
question you write about the wall street
grabbing of tensions is that involves
public and private and can it be stopped
can they be controlled and as I put too
much risk to our public and private
pensions I'll take my answer here thank
you
great thanks yeah well so I wrote a lot
about that in in the last eight years in
a couple of different levels one is you
know there's the whole question of who
is managing public pension funds and
that's that that's a separate issue
there's a whole question of
are we paying exorbitant fees for hedge
funds that don't perform terribly well
to manage our money you know I talked to
somebody who managed the pension fund a
Illinois and a public pension fund and
he said look you know I'm paying like
you know a few pennies to invest the
workers money in this gigantic index
fund and it outperformed these hedge
funds that I'd have to pay tens of
millions of dollars to manage so why
would I bother because over a long
period of time and all pension funds are
essentially long-term investments index
funds are going to do just fine for the
most part so does that issue but the
issue that's more pertinent to the stuff
that I did was the fact that when we
were when these gigantic financial
companies were selling properties like
these toxic subprime mortgage
instruments they very often targeted
these big institutional investors like
pension funds because what they would do
is they would it would take some state
employee who manages these funds who
might make seventy five or a hundred
thousand dollars and they take the
person to Vegas or to the Super Bowl and
hang out with them for a week and then
that person next thing you know is
buying twenty million dollars worth of
some product and what happened in the
financial crisis that we saw losses of
you know 25 30 35 percent across the
board in these in these pension funds
private and public because they were
buying huge masses of these these um you
know essentially worthless subprime
mortgage instruments it was it was a
snake-oil game you know it's the same
thing as people calling up your your
grandparents and offering them you know
overpriced magazine subscriptions you
know you think you know you have a
vulnerable buyer and you just sell them
as much as you can of a worthless
product now that's what happened in the
financial crisis that was so so
disturbing and so predatory and
sociopathic but it wasn't terribly well
explained to the public and that that's
one of the things that I was trying to
get at that's how a B if somebody wanted
to pick up one of your books which one
would you recommend to them right now
probably the divide I think that that's
the one
you know happiest about it came out in
2014
yeah the you know it's good I spent a
lot of time reporting on that book and I
think it you know just it was it's the
most elaborate of the books that I've
written but I have one other one coming
out later this year that I've been um
that I'm really excited about it's about
the Eric garner case here in New York
and so I'm really looking forward to
seeing how that that that one comes out
the divided income inequality
incarceration inequality yeah two main
topics yeah basically you know I I had
been covering white-collar crime for a
long period of time when I started
writing this book and at after a period
of time I kept running to get up against
this issue of man these guys are doing
these incredible scams and they're
ripping off enormous sums of money and
then some of them are brilliant they're
amazing crimes within their complexity
but they're not doing any time they even
when they get caught they never get
punished for it and so I in order to try
to bring out for readers how outrageous
and ridiculous that was I had to try to
understand how easy it was for other
people to go to jail and that was
something I didn't know a whole lot
about and so the divide is really kind
of this exploration where I go to these
various places when I talk to people who
who have been imprisoned and how they
got to jail and how easy it is for an
ordinary person who just sort of on the
streets to end up end up you know with a
record
whereas I follow these other cases that
are incredibly elaborate and destructive
and in the end nobody ends up having to
pay a single cent or do a time at you a
day in jail and it's it's a story that
you can't tell unless it's a comparing
contrasting size and so that's that's
what this is it's kind of this vast
exercise and so they're showing the two
different justice systems lee is in
rockville maryland and lee your own book
TV good afternoon good afternoon and
gentlemen
a really great show today Peter I used
to enjoy hearing you and Imus in the
morning
of course that's not on anymore Matt but
anyway it was used to had you really had
some good banter with him a lot a lot of
good banter with him I you and I are old
enough to remember when the Communist
world was known as the Red Menace and
the godless commies things like that
when the Cold War was going on and with
good reason
now of course the country called Russia
is run by a by a KGB thug by the name of
the flat amir putin and he's cut out of
the same cloth
they still murder people they still do
all these terrible things all around the
world they they support the genocide
alor regime in syria they're they're not
the Red Menace anymore they're not the
evil empire that Reagan used to call
them but they're a bunch of gangsters
and thugs yet yet we have a president
who's constantly singing the praises of
the Russians his National Security
Advisor initially Flynn was in bed with
them his son-in-law is in bed with them
this is outrageous
absolutely outrageous I don't get it Lee
is that at the point that is outrageous
or did you want to ask another question
okay that's it outrageous
got it okay I mean look I I was in
Russia when Vladimir Putin became
president I wrote long long features
about how horrible he was back then I
was I knew I knew exactly who he was I
knew where he came from
I I was colleagues with people with
reporters who were subsequently
disappeared people like Anna
Politkovskaya and eurasia ketchikan
people who are dead today
you know because because they didn't get
along with the Putin regime you know no
one is more sensitive than me to the
the iniquity of Vladimir Putin's Russia
my I am totally aware of that I I just I
think that it's a little bit of a
stretch though to to say that let me
just have to put it this way four years
ago Barack
oh and Barack Obama was debating Mitt
Romney on television and Romney said
that Russia was the biggest threat
facing the world Barack Obama said the
80s want their foreign policy back and
he suggests that look Russia is what it
is but it's probably better for us to
get along or find some way to not be
completely hostile enemies with them
then then to go back to what it was in
the past and I think that there's some
merit to that look we're two nuclear
powers what happened in Syria was an
incredibly dangerous thing when when
Trump was lobbying lobbing missiles into
into Syria and there are Russian forces
on the ground there I mean you know
that's that's a very very tense
situation that's that's the thing that I
worry about most of all with the Trump
administration is nuclear war and Russia
is what it is you know you don't have to
agree with it I don't I don't like the
regime there I've never liked the regime
there but if we're probably better off
not in a constant state of hostility
with Russia and that we are in one at
least that's my experience and you know
of course if you asked Russia about
Russians about what their view of
Americans is that they will have almost
exactly the same things to say about us
for instance if you think about the 1996
election which I was also there for in
Russia we openly meddled in that
election we sent advisors to the Boris
Yeltsin campaign if you if you look at
time on Time magazine and July of 1996
there's a picture of Boris Yeltsin and
there's a headline into the Yanks to the
rescue because we openly bragged about
how we helped him win reelection and the
Russians still resent that
so there's there's angst on both sides
and yes it's a terrible regime yes the
third-world regime and they abused
journalists and they and they crack down
on all kinds of freedoms and they
support awful regimes and that's who
they are but we're better off not at war
with them than we are without work with
them Tyler in East Lansing Michigan home
of Michigan State emails in I was
pleased to see you discussing Jonathan
hates very important book the righteous
mind in that spirit what do you see as
conservatives best point and what do you
see as the biggest shortcoming the best
point of conservatives yes and their
biggest shortcoming or a best point a
shortcoming if that's easier rather than
putting you on the spot for the best I
think you know there's a complaint out
there in conservative America that you
know that's certain that the liberal
mind and liberal media has become more
orthodox and unaccepting of ideas and
more hostile I don't know if that's true
or not but I think that you know from
their point of view from conservatives
point of view what they would say is
liberals run Hollywood they run the
media they run campuses and we see our
world being taken over and that's why
we're so angry and I'm not sure that
that you know that that it's a
completely invalid point of view I think
I think that there is some truth to the
fact that that you know the conservative
point of view is often excluded
automatically you know do I agree with
it no but you know I think that that it
does happen but you know in terms of
their weakest point of view just take
that caller before who is talking about
how the black and Hispanic people are
the root of all evil I mean I think that
that kind of talk has become
increasingly normalized in especially
the kind of fringe conservative media
and stuff that you see on a lot of those
sites now is
is scary to me frankly a couple of
Facebook comments let's take them in
order this is Harley enjoyed you and IMS
I would like to know if you think Trump
can really make a difference in fighting
global terror bombings including the
recent stuff going on in England I don't
think so
I think Trump is uniquely unsuited to
deal with the terrorism problem I think
it's the problem of enormous complexity
it requires it requires somebody who has
a profound knowledge of all the
different relationships and historical
grievances of in the region in in the
Middle East I think Aniki need to have
somebody who knows the difference
between Egypt and Yemen and between the
Shiites and the Sunnis and the you know
and Donald Trump doesn't know the
difference in any of that stuff it's
just all one big area that needs to be
bombed to him you know and I think
that's been a failing of American
foreign policies our unwillingness to to
kind of learn about what's going on in
that part of the world it was it was a
problem when we invaded Iraq frankly you
know that we had this incredibly
simplistic idea that we were going to go
in there and the tanks were going to
roll in it was going to be Switzerland
six weeks later you know in this great
flowering of Western values was going to
take place in that and we did that
because we had no idea who these people
were we weren't interested in their
point of view and we didn't care about
their history their pride in their
culture nothing and you know so there
are problems over there but we're not
going to solve it just by like shaking
our fists and dropping bombs on it I
don't think that worse Joseph Oppenheim
posts on Facebook Matt the world is the
most peaceful prosperous healthy etc
this is coincided with the growth of
capitalism big banks multinational
companies etc thus aren't you naive to
think that the little guy is being
screwed I don't know I mean once you ask
the little guy I would say that incomes
in this country have been real incomes
have been declining steadily since 1970
you know
the the inequality has grown at an
enormous rate you know the top 1% of the
country is making you know dozens of
times what it was making relative to the
rest of the country even 40 or 50 years
ago and yes if you look at overall it at
the level of wealth in places like China
you might see a better standard of
living but in other parts of the world
which we've seen other phenomenon that
are that are entirely negative like the
growth of inequality like the collapse
of sovereign nations in play in third
world places in Africa you know we've
we've just seen less order in the world
in the last 30 or 40 years so yeah and I
understand that there that that global
capitalism has resulted in a lot of
progress but if there are there issues
to and those underlying Clee a lot of
the political grievances that are going
on in stacy's days Sean and Kaneohe
Hawaii we have one minute left go ahead
Oh
from a white almost called cosmopolitan
stating a union that being mindful of
Allah have you ever what's your favorite
Hawaiian and Filipino food and cuz your
Rolling Stone writer what's your
favorite album or Ben oh wow Mahalo
I like hallo hallo frankly at a Filipino
food what is that it's like this crazy
ice cream ish kind of thing I don't even
know how to explain it well my wife's
Filipino also so we we eat you know a
little bit of Filipino food at home
every now and then so and Hawaiian food
I don't know I don't even know why I
want so you know I and I've never met my
relatives there was a matter of fact so
I'm ignorant as far as that goes albums
I have the worst musical taste in the
world and I'm too embarrassed to share
my musical preferences with people on
the air so that that's why they keep me
away from intricate Rolling Stone it
never never asked me to write about it
does it involve disco or the Bee Gees
ready no I I mean I like rap music a lot
so but I like everything frankly I just
the you know I think an ordinary person
her but I listen to they would think it
was real real geek one more than they do
now have you noticed that your books
over the years this came out in the mid
Ott's smells like dead elephants your
name is down there at the bottom but
then this year your name is great big
letter I only noticed that it although
your name is growing no I hadn't thought
about that
but that's cool though I guess right
yeah all right for the last three hours
Matt Taibbi has been our guest on both
TVs in-depth program very quickly here's
a list of his books
beginning with the Exile which came out
in 2000 it's about sex drugs and libel
in the new Russia spanking the donkey
dispatches from the dump season came out
after the O for election smells like
dead elephants dispatches from a rotting
Empire came out in 2007 the great
derangement came out in 2009 Griff topia
the story of bankers politicians in the
most audacious power grab in American
history 2011 the divide which mister
Taibbi recommends as the book to pick up
America American injustice in the age of
the wealth gap came out in 2014 and his
most recent book this year insane clown
president mr. Teddy thank you for your
time on balloon computer thank you